ओके
स वी आर लाइव नाउ आई थिंक लेट मी चेक
व चेक कर लेता
हूं
या
टली मैंने चेक कर लिया है इट्स ल
गुड प्लीज टेल मी गाइस एम ऑडिबल एंड
विजिबल क्लियर क्लियर है बता दीजिए जरा
जल्दी से बता दीजिए क्या मैं क्लियर दिख
रहा हूं आप लोगों
को प्
ल ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
क्लियर ओके
ओके तो सब कुछ सही है ऑडियो वीडियो
एवरीथिंग गुड एवरीथिंग गुड गाइस प्लीज टेल
मी सब कुछ बढ़िया
ना गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग सबको गुड
इवनिंग
ओके ओके ग्रेट वी आर गुड टू गो एंड गुड
इवनिंग एवरी बडी ओके तो चलिए तो चलिए चलिए
चलिए स्टार्ट करते हैं आज का सेशन ज्यादा
टाइम आपका मैं वेस्ट नहीं करूंगा एंड अ आज
से हमारा जो बक बाउंट है जो फ्री कोर्स है
वह स्टार्ट होता है एंड सबसे पहले वेलकम
एवरीवन दिस फर्स्ट डे ऑफ अ बग
बाउंटीज गोइंग टू एंड कब पता नहीं मुझे भी
क्योंकि यह जो कोर्स है वह बिल्कुल जीरो
से स्टार्ट करने वाला हूं मैं अगर आप में
से कोई भी बंदा बग बाउंट को कुछ मतलब कुछ
नहीं जानता बग बाउंट के बारे में कुछ भी
नहीं पता था उसको अब तक पी भी नहीं पता
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का पी नहीं पता स्टिल
यू कैन वच दिस सीरीज दिस वीडियोस विल कम
इन दिस सीरीज एंड अगले तीन महीने के अंदर
में आई कैन प्रॉमिस यू आप जो अभी जिस लेवल
पे हो ना उससे कई गुना ज्यादा लेवल प
रहोगे यू विल बिकम अ प्रो यू विल बिकम अ
मास्टर इन बग बाउंट इट्स माय गारंटी मैं
गारंटी आपको देता हूं क्योंकि मैं वैसा ही
कंटेंट आपको ना इस सीरीज में जो आपको यकीन
नहीं होने वाला है और आपकी जो एक
मेंटालिटी होती है ना काफी लोगों की
मेंटालिटी होती है ना आप सबको पता ही होगा
मेंटालिटी क्या होती है गाइस कि कि
मेंटालिटी होती है कि फ्री में क्वालिटी
कंटेंट नहीं ये मेंटालिटी है ना आप सबकी
मुझे बता दो मतलब मोस्टली 90 पर ऑफ द पीपल
थिंक कि फ्री में क्वालिटी कंटेंट नहीं
मिलती है एंड एक्चुअली होता भी है मतलब
फ्री में बहुत ज्यादा क्वालिटी नहीं मिलती
है मैंने देखा है खुद ने भी मैंने
एक्सपीरियंस करा है यह रियल फैक्ट है ठीक
है मतलब थोड़ा बहुत चार्ज करते हैं तो वो
थोड़ा क्वालिटी कंटेंट देते हैं राइट एम
आई राइट आर यू ग्रीड बट यहां पे यह जो बग
बाउंट की जो क्लास आपकी यह पूरी सीरीज
होने वाली है ना
ये उस क्वालिटी की मिलने वाली है कि आपका
यह जो ये जो जो थिंग थॉट है ना वो चेंज हो
जाएगा ये कंप्लीट चेंज हो जाएगा क्योंकि
क्वालिटी आपको फ्री में मिलेगी एकदम टॉप
नॉच ठीक है तो
चलिए
ओके चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं आज से एंड
काफी टाइम आपने वेट किया है थैंक यू सो मच
वेट करने के लिए सीरीज का क्योंकि मुझे
पता है मैं काफी टाइम से बोल रहा था बट एक
सही टाइम का वेट कर रहा था क्योंकि उसके
पहले मुझे बैश को कंप्लीट करवाना था उसके
पहले मुझे ओट काली लिनिक्स कंप्लीट कर
उसके पहले मुझे आपका पाइथन भी करवाना था
सब कुछ उसके पहले नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
करवानी थी सब कुछ जब हो गया तो आया हमारा
बग बाउटी एंड वी आर गोइंग टू स्टार्ट इट
तो सबसे पहले यह बग बाउटी सीरीज हमारी
डेनिक्स कंपनी के तरफ से आपके लिए लेकर आई
गई है और यह सीरीज चलेगी हमारे डेनिक्स
एडमी
[संगीत]
बिकॉज आई हैव अ
youtube0 के से ज्यादा सब्सक्राइबर्स हैं
तो वो चैनल में बहुत पहले से रन करता आ
रहा हूं एज अ पार्ट टाइम मैं उसपे वीडियोस
डालता हूं साइबर सिक्योरिटी
दैट्ची कंपनी एंड मैंने लगभग 5000 से भी
ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा है बट ये मैंने आपको
एक वैल्यू बताई है स्टूडेंट्स को
प्रोफेशनल्स को ट्रेन करा है मेरे काफी
स्टूडेंट्स ऑलरेडी दे आर वर्किंग इन
कंपनीज ठीक है एंड यहां पे मैंने गाइस अ
मतलब इस फील्ड में अभी तक ऑलमोस्ट 10
इयर्स हो चुके हैं मेरे को इस फील्ड में
जब मैंने स्टार्ट किया था तो मेरे पास वो
सारी एक्सपर्टाइज्ड
कर सकता हूं इस बग बाउंट जर्नी में ठीक है
एंड अगेन मैंने आपको पहले भी बताया था आई
एम नॉट अ फुल टाइम बग हंटर एक फुल टाइम बा
घंटा नहीं हूं बट इस सीरीज में मैं आपके
साथ-साथ हंट करूं यानी कि यू आर गोइंग टू
हंट विद मी आई एम गोइंग टू हंट विद यू तो
अगर आप इस चीज को फॉलो कर रहे हैं ना तो
बिलीव मी हर कुछ सबसे पहले तो बिल्कुल
स्क्रैच से होगा बिल्कुल स्क्रैच से होगा
तो जो मैं करूं आपको करना है जो मैं
समझाऊं आपको समझना है जो मैं आपको बताऊं
वो भी आपको सीख नहीं करोगे तो पीछे रह और
साथ में करोगे तो म आ जाएगा ठीक है
एवरीथिंग यू हैव टू डू अलोंग
तो चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं
ओके सो यह हमारी सोशल प्रेजेंस है जहां पे
आप देख सकते हैं हमारी एक
instagram.com वेबसाइट है तो स्टार्ट करते
हैं आज का सेशन व्हाट यू विल लर्न टुडे आज
आप क्या सीखने वाले हैं सेशन में अब देखो
मैं एक चीज बताता हूं आप लोगों को मैं
आपसे ही पूछता हूं चलो आप ही मुझे जवाब दो
आपको आपको फास्ट जाना है ठीक है फास्ट
जाना है इस सीरीज में मतलब थोड़ा जो आपका
पेस है वो फास्ट होगा या आपको स्लो एंड
स्टडी जाना है एंड बहुत ही आराम आराम से
जाना है मुझे आप लोग पहले बता दो चैट में
लेट मी नो इन द चैट सेक्शन प्लीज लेट मी
नो आपको कैसे जाना
है प्लीज लेट मी नो एंड वी हैव 12 एट लाइव
व्यूवर्स करेंटली गाइस दैट इज अ रिकॉर्ड
दैट इज ग्रेट रिकॉर्ड नाइस चलिए बता दीजिए
मुझे आपको स्टडी जाना है या बहुत ही अच्छे
से एडवांस में स्लो एंड स्टेडी जाना है या
फास्ट जाना है स्लो एंड स्टडी जानी है या
फास्ट जाना है यानी कि यू हैव टू बिकम अ
टोटोज और अ रैबिट मुझे बस इतना बताइए तब
तक मैं इधर देख लूं ये लाइव वाला सेक्शन
टोटॉयज और रैबिट मुझे बस ये जाना है यू
वांट टू बिकम अ टोटॉयज और
रैबिट ओके स्लो एंड स्टेडी ग्रेट ग्रेट
ग्रेट ओके
ओके ओके
ग्रेट नाइस चलिए बहुत बढ़िया
तोच से एंड यू वांट टू बिकम अ स्लो एंड
स्टेडी ओके रैबिट कुछ लोगों को रैबिट बनना
है रैबिट का मतलब आप समझे नहीं शायद टट
बनना है बिल्कुल टट
तो हम स्लो एंड स्टडी जाएंगे एंड हर कुछ
बेसिक से लेकर चलेंगे और अगर आपने मिस करा
यह सेशंस को मिस करें यह वीडियोस मिस करें
तो आप बहुत कुछ मिस करेंगे मैं आपको
गारंटी देता हूं मैं आपको एक चीज की
गारंटी देता हूं ना मैं आपको बग हंटर बना
के रहूंगा इस सीरीज के एंड होते-होते और
ये सीरीज एंड कब तक होगी अप्रॉक्स नेक्स्ट
छ महीने अप्रॉक्स तो टेंशन नहीं लेना
धीरे-धीरे चलना है न महीने के अंदर आप
अपने आप में चेंजेज देखने लगोगे अभी आप
यहां हो ना यू विल बी एट दिस प्लेस आप जिस
पोजीशन पे हो उससे कई गुना ज्यादा आप
पोजीशंस पे उस टाइम पे रहोगे इस माय
गारंटी चलिए तो व्हाट इज बग बाउटी एंड
स्कोप काली एंड ट्रा हकमी के बारे में
जानेंगे बग बाउटी प्लेटफॉर्म्स के बारे
में जानेंगे ओस टॉप 10 के बारे में
जानेंगे जो कि काफी जरूरी है चेकलिस्ट के
बारे में जानेंगे और कैसे क्या सेटअप करना
है सब कुछ जानेंगे आज के सेशन में सबसे
पहले स्टार्ट करते हैं व्हाट इज बग बाउंट
अब ये मुझे डेफिनेशन बताने के लिए मैंने
ये नहीं लिखा हुआ है कि आपको मैं डेफिनेशन
बताऊं ये आप कहीं से ग करेंगे चार जीबीटी
करेंगे आपको सेम डेफिनेशन मिल जाएगी यहां
पे मुझे आपको समझाना है कि बग बाउंट होता
क्या है व्हाई यू नीड टू बिकम अ बग बाउंट
हंटर आपको बनना क्यों है भाई बग बाउटी
हंटर बनना क्यों है साब सिक्योरिटी के
बहुत सारे डोमेन है कैन गो इन दैट ब व्हाई
टू चूज एज अ बग बाउंट हंटर बग हंटर सिक्य
पेटस टेस्टर क्योंकि बग बाउंट जो आपको ये
डोमेन है ना ये साइबर सिक्योरिटी का बग
बाउंट बनने का जो एक डोमेन जिसमें आप वक
बाउटी हंटर बन जाते हैं ये डोमेन अपने आप
में बहुत इस डोमेन की डिमांड कभी भी खत्म
नहीं होने वाली है नेवर एवर ये लिख के रखो
मान के चलो कभी खत्म नहीं होगी ए आई आ जाए
या कुछ भी आ जाए इट विल नॉट गेट वनिश्ड
नेवर
एवर ठीक है तो ये दिमाग से निकाल देना है
कि एआई का क्या इंपैक्ट पड़ेगा बग बाउंट
बग बाउंट हंटर्स के ऊपर या बग हंटर्स के
ऊपर क्या इंपैक्ट पड़ेगा कुछ इंपैक्ट नहीं
पड़ने वाला है जैसे-जैसे एआई अपने आप को
इवॉल्व करेगा बग हंटिंग का जो प्रोसेस है
मेथड लॉजी है वो भी इवॉल्व होती जाएगी एआई
आएगी तो एआई सिक्योरिटी की जरूरत पड़ेगी
दैट विल आल्सो बी उसमें भी आप बक्स फाइंड
करोगे ना लेबिलिटी फाइंड करोगे अब बात
करते हैं बग बाउंट है क्या बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम यह है क्या देखो बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम जो है ना ये एक तरह का
प्रोग्राम एक तरह का इनिशिएटिव ऐसा है जो
कंपनीज या ऑर्गेनाइजेशन रन करती है क्यों
रन करती है मेरी कंपनी है मेरा एक
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है डिफ्रॉक साइबर अब मेरी
कंपनी जो है एक अच्छे ले आ चुकी है बड़े
लेवल पर आ चुकी है बट मेरी कंपनी का जो
डाटा है मेरी कंपनी की जो इंफॉर्मेशन है
मेरी कंपनी का जो इंपोर्टेंट जो एसेट है
ना वह सब क्लाउड में है वह सब क इंटरनेट प
उसके होगा क्या इंटरनेट प अब इंटरनेट प है
तो क्या है अनसिक्योर है बिल्कुल
सिक्योरिटी नहीं है एंड उस को सिक्योर
करना है मुझे सिक्योर करके रखना है उसके
लिए किसकी जरूरत पड़ेगी मुझे इंटरनेट पर
किसी भी चीज की किसी भी चीज को सिक्योर
रखने के लिए किसकी जरूरत पड़ेगी मुझे
बताइए आप चैट में बताइए जल्दी से इंटरनेट
पर किसी भी चीज को सिक्योर रखना हो तो
आपको किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी कौन चाहिए
होगा मुझे बताइए आप लोग
जल्दी प्लीज लेट मी
नो एंड वॉइस इज ब्रेकिंग सम टाइम्स वॉइस इ
ब्रेकिंग लेट मी चेक प्लीज लेट मी
चेक करेंटली इट्स
क्लियर नाउ इट्स क्लियर ओके लेट मी रिमूव
वन फिल्टर हियर मुझे बताइए किसकी
रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी जल्दी
बताइए े बताइए किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
पड़ेगी
हेलो हेलो ओके एवरीथिंग इज फाइन
नाउ ओके तो अभी सही है ना सब कुछ बिकॉज
थोड़ा बहुत इशू आ जाते हैं थोड़े बहुत
इंटरनेट कनेक्टिविटी की वजह से आ जाते हैं
बट अभी सही होंगे ना राइट चलिए
हैकर
हैकर या एथिकल हैकर की रिक्वायरमेंट
पड़ेगी राइट एथिकल हैकर की रिक्वायरमेंट
पड़ेगी राइट राइट किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट
पड़ेगी एथिकल हैकर की रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी
वी नीड एथिकल हैकर्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल्स उनकी रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी
राइट और क्या चाहिए यही तो यही तो यही तो
मैं पूछ रहा था एथिकल हैकर की
रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल की रिक्वायरमेंट पड़ेगी तो अब
मैं उनको खोजू उनको सर्च करूंगा तो मेरे
पास मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस हैं क्या है या तो मैं
अपना एक बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम रन करूं
अलग-अलग बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे
सिक्योरिटी प्लेटफॉर्म्स पे क्राउड सोर्स
प्लेटफॉर्म्स हो या अन या लाइक नॉन क्राउड
सोर्स प्लेटफॉर्म्स हो वो अलग-अलग चीजें
हैं मैं बताऊंगा डिस्कस करूंगा बट मैं
अपना एक बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम रन करूंगा
राइट एंड मैं इनवाइट करूंगा उन सारे एथिकल
हैकर्स सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस को कम एंड हंट
ऑन माय एसेट्स एसेट्स में क्या हो सकते
हैं एसेट्स में मेरी वेबसाइट हो सकती है
मेरा एंड एप्लीकेशन हो सकता है मेरा गिट
हब रिपोजिटरी हो सकता है मेरा एपीआई हो
सकता है मेरी हार्डवेयर भी हो सकती है
मेरा नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर हो सकता
है ना हर चीज हो सकता है यह हम एसेट इसी
को हम एसेट बोलते हैं दिस इज नोन एज एसेट
तो हम एसेट पे इनवाइट करेंगे सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चर को कि आप इस पे आइए हंट कीजिए और
उसके बदले में हम आपको कुछ ना कुछ तो
देंगे अब जैसे हमारी कंपनी स्टार्टअप है
तो हम मॉनेटरी बेनिफिट ज्यादा नहीं दे
सकते तो हम क्या करेंगे हम कुछ पॉइंट्स दे
देंगे उस वर्क बाउंट प्लेटफार्म के ऊपर या
फिर हम क्या करेंगे हम कुछ रिवार्ड्स में
स्वैग्स वगैरह कुछ टीशर्ट्स वगैरह दे
देंगे कुछ कॉफी मग वगैरह दे देंगे देंगे
कैप वगैरह दे देंगे पेन दे देंगे व्हाट
एवर देयर इज या फिर हम हॉल ऑफ फेम दे
देंगे कि आप हमारी वेबसाइट पे आप हमारे इस
प्लेटफॉर्म पे आप हमारे उस पर्टिकुलर
रिसर्चर ग्रुप के पार्ट हो जाएंगे
जिन्होंने कुछ वैलिड बग फाइंड किए है
हमारी सिक्योरिटी को स्थन करने में मजबूत
करने में हमें हेल्प करी है और अगर हमारी
कंपनी अच्छी खासी ग्रोथ कर चुकी है हमारे
पास अच्छी खासी मोनेटरी वैल्यूज आ चुकी है
तो हम आपको बाउंट यानी पैसे भी दे सकते
हैं बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनीज तो बहुत अच्छा खासा
पैसा बहुत अच्छा खासा पे करती है तो इसलिए
यह जो बग बाउंट है ना यह बहुत ज्यादा
डिमांडिंग
है बहुत ज्यादा डिमांडिंग डोमेन है इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी बिलीव मी बहुत ही ज्यादा
डिमांडिंग है जिसकी कोई कोई लिमिटेशन नहीं
है ठीक है मैं एक तरफ अ यह जो वीडियो है
इसको प्ले करके रख देता हूं ताकि आपके कुछ
भी इश्यूज आए तो मुझे पता चल जाए राइट अभी
एवरीथिंग एवरीथिंग इज ओके ऑडियो वीडियो
क्योंकि क्योंकि मुझे ये पूछना पड़ता है
राइट ठीक है ये डिमांडिंग है अब टोटल आपका
मोटिव क्या होता है बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम रन
करने का मोटिव क्या है मोटिव है कि इस
पर्टिकुलर कंपनी का ऑर्गेनाइजेशन का जो
सिक्योरिटी है उसको स्ट्रेंथ करना उसको
मजबूत करना उसको टाइट करना एंड इसी के लिए
बग बाउंट हंटर्स की रिक्वायरमेंट है बग
हंटर्स की रिक्वायरमेंट है सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चस की रिक्वायरमेंट है यही आपको बनना
है और आप बनेंगे
बनेंगे एंड 110 पर मैं बना के रहूंगा इस
सीरीज में यह आप लिख के रखिए अब आपका रोल
क्या-क्या हो सकता है एज अ वर्क बाउंट
हंटर यानी अगर आप बग हंटिंग सीख रहे हैं
जैसे आपने ये सीरीज में आप ये सीरीज को कर
रहे हैं सीरीज को आपने कंप्लीट कर लिया
आपके पास स्किल्स आने शुरू हो गए या आपने
कल करना शुरू कर दिया तो आपके आप
क्या-क्या रोल के लिए अजूम कर सकते हैं
अपने आप को एक कंपनी के अंदर में तो देयर
आर मल्टीपल रोल्स बहुत सारे रोल्स होते
हैं कुछ रोल्स ही मैंने लिस्ट करे हैं
लेकिन इसके अलावे भी बहुत सारे रोल्स होते
हैं सबसे पहला सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर आप बन
सकते हैं पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर का रोल आपको
मिल सकता है सिक्योरिटी कंसल्टेंट का रोल
मिल सकता है सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर का रोल
मिल सकता है सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट का रोल
मिल सकता है इंसिडेंट रिस्पांडर का रोल
मिल सकता है साइबर थ्रेट हंटर का रोल मिल
सकता है सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशंस में भी आप जा
सकते हैं सिक्योरिटी आर्किटेक्ट भी बन
सकते हैं यू कैन बिकम एनीथिंग रिलेटेड टू
दिस डोमेन तो आपका प्राइमरी फोकस जो रहेगा
काम जो रहेगा वो रहेगा कंपनी के एसेट की
सुरक्षा करना को गार्ड करना अपने टेक्निकल
स्किल्स से अपने बग बाउंट बग हंटिंग स्किल
से ठीक है यह आपका काम रहेगा
चलिए अब यहां पर हम जानते हैं पहले कि बग
बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स
जहां पर बग बाउंट के प्रोग्राम्स लिस्ट
होते हैं वो कौन-कौन से हैं ऐसे मतलब ह
प्लस बग बाउटी प्लेटफॉर्म्स है बिलीव मी
बहुत सारे प्लेटफॉर्म्स उनमें से कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स मैंने लिस्ट किए
हैं जैसे हैकर वन डिटेक्टिव फाइ बग क्राउड
सिनेक कोबाल्ट ओपन बग बाउंट रो कॉप्टर यस
व हैक कैन प्रूव ब एंटी हैक फायर बाउंट बग
बाउंट जेपी इंटीग्रिटी बहुत सारे ऐसे
प्लेटफॉर्म्स
है बट इनमें से बहुत ज्यादा जो पॉपुलर है
ना वो आपका तीन प्लेटफॉर्म ओपन बग बाउंट
बग क्राउड हैकर वन उसके बाद आपका
इंटीग्रिटी भी आता है सवी हैक भी आता है
ऐसे और सिनेक भी आते हैं बहुत सारे ऐसे
प्लेटफॉर्म्स सा है जो काफी पॉपुलर है
अमंग द
रिसर्चस यह आपको समझ में आ गया यह
प्लेटफॉर्म्स वो प्लेटफॉर्म्स है जो आपको
बग बाउंट की प्रोग्राम्स को देते हैं जिस
परे आप हंट कर सकते हैं अब बारी आती है कि
आप कैसे प्लेटफॉर्म पे हंट करेंगे भाई किस
टाइप के प्लेटफॉर्म पे यू आर गोइंग टू हंट
क्यों हंट करेंगे कौन से प्रोग्राम पे हंट
करेंगे वो सब हम जानेंगे देखो हम
प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट पे भी अभी आने वाले हैं
तो इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है बहुत आराम
आराम से मैं जा रहा हूं बहुत रिलैक्सिंग
वे में जा रहा हूं सब कुछ धीरे-धीरे आपको
समझाते चलूंगा एक एक स्टेप वाइज चलूंगा
एंड सबसे पहला हा अब मुझे जानना है आपसे
मैं अपने फोन में भी यहां पर चैट ओपन कर
रखा है मुझे बता दीजिए जल्दी से आप में से
सबसे पहले बग बाउंट का बग हंटिंग का या
एथिकल हैकिंग का सबसे पहला फेज कौन सा
होता है आप में से किसी को पता है सबसे
पहला फेज द वेरी फर्स्ट फेज उसको हम क्या
बोलते हैं टेक्निकल टर्म क्या है प्लीज
बताइए मुझे प्लीज लेट मी
नो प्लीज लेट मी
नो ओके अ स्पर्स इज सेइंग अ रिकॉन स्प नील
अ वी विल डू लाइव वेबसाइट टेस्टिंग यस
एब्सलूट वी विल डू लैब्स आल्सो लाइव
वेबसाइट्स आल्सो जहां पे हम हंट करेंगे
जहां जो जो बग क्राउड या आपको हैकर वन के
प्लेटफॉर्म से या ओपन बग बाउटी वहां पे
करेंगे लाइव करेंगे ठीक है टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है सो यहां पे काफी लोगों के अ
रिप्लाई आ रहे हैं मुझे रिकन सेंस रिकन
सेंस रिकॉन इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग रेकन ओके ग्रेट चलिए तो काफी
लोगों को ऑलरेडी पता है सबसे पहला जो
स्टेप होता है ना वो रेकन होता है यानी कि
रिकॉन सेंस यानी कि इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग बग बाउंट की भी शुरुआत इसी से
होती है एथिकल हैकिंग की शुरुआत इसी से
होती है आपको किसी टारगेट पे हंट करना है
आपको उसके अंदर लेबिलिटी फाइंड करनी है तो
भैया आपको उसके रिलेटेड जितनी इंफॉर्मेशन
है वो तो निकालनी पड़े ना यार मैं यहां पर
यह वाली स्टैंड लगा लेता हूं मुझे सामने
दिखेगा यह चैट है ना अब सही है तो आपको
उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन तो निकालनी पड़ेगी ना यार
बिना इंफॉर्मेशन निकाले उस पर कैसे हंट
करोगे उसकी जितनी इंफॉर्मेशन निचोड़ के
रखनी है ना वो आपको नि छोड़नी है एंड यहीं
पर आप यकीन मानो ना कि 70 पर आप यहां पर
सक्सेसफुल हो जाते हो 70 वन बिलिटी ना आप
सिर्फ रेकन से फाइंड कर सकते हो सच में वो
कोई भी लेबिलिटी हो आप एक्सएसएस की बात
करो एसकल इंजेक्शन की बात करो आप सोर्स
कोस डिस्क्लोजर की बात करो आप सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन डिस्क्लोजर की बात करो व्हाट
एवर यू टॉक अबाउट यू आर गोइंग टू गेट दैट
वलने बिलिटी विथ रेकन ओनली 70
पर सोचो हाउ पावरफुल रेकन इज बट हम लोग
क्या है ना रेकन को बहुत बहुत ना लाइक
अंडर रेटेड चीज है यह रेकन बहुत अंडररेटेड
है एंड बिलीव मी हम सबसे पहले इस पूरे बग
बाउंट सीरीज में ना रेकन को कवर करने वाले
हैं एंड रेकन प इतना डिटेल जाएंगे ना इतना
डिटेल जाएंगे जितना आपने सोचा ही नहीं
होगा आप सोचोगे कि सर ये रेकन कब तक है कब
तक चलेगा क्या-क्या चीजें हैं इसमें रेकन
ओशन है समंदर है उसके अंदर और सारे
स्टेप्स है समा जाते हैं सच में सारे
स्टेप्स उसके अंदर आ जाते हैं इतना डेंजरस
रिकॉन आप में से कोई अगर यहां प्रोफेशनल
बग बाउंट हंटर है मे बी हो सकता है या कोई
बक बाउंट करता है ना भी हो प्रोफेशनल तो
भी उसको पता होगा रेकन की पावर का ही मस्ट
बी नोइंग हाउ पावरफुल रेकन इ एनी वन हियर
हु डू बग बाउंडी लेट मी नो एनी वन एनी
वन
प्लीज
ओके इस कोर्स का कोई वैलिडिटी नहीं है पूछ
रहे हैं यहां पर कितने दिन तक ये कोर्स
चलेगा भैया यह कोर्स चलता ही जाएगा तुम
बात समझ लो तुम इस बात को समझो मुझे
तुम्हें बग बाउंट हंटर बनाना है बग हंटर
बनाना है प्रो बनाना है जीरो से अगर जीरो
हो तो अगर ऑलरेडी जानते हो तो भी अच्छा है
और ज्यादा जान जाओगे बट जीरो से प्रो
बनाना है मुझे अब यह कब तक बनेगा आई डोंट
नो मुझे नहीं
पता ओके कुछ लोग हैं जो करते हैं कुछ लोग
बहुत लोग नहीं भी करते हैं नॉट एन इशू कोई
टेंशन नहीं है अपने साथ रहो सब करने लग
ठीक है सब सब करने लगोगे ओके तो यहां पर
सब हम रेकन को इतनी डिटेल में लेकर जाएंगे
ना कि आपको रेकन से ही सब कुछ समझ में आने
लगेगा एंड बिलीव मी रेकन करोगे ना बढ़िया
से तो आप तो वैसे ही बहुत सारी वन
एबिलिटीज बक्स को फाइंड कर लोगे बहुत सारे
वटी को फाइंड कर लोगे यस राजू वी विल
आल्सो परफॉर्म ऑन लाइव टारगेट्स आल्सो जब
हम उस सेक्शन में आएंगे जब हम उस पार्ट प
आएंगे हम लाइव वेबसाइट्स पर भी हंट करेंगे
डोंट वरी अबाउट दैट राइट या
अब्सोल्युटली चलिए तो यह प्लेटफॉर्म्स है
यहां पे एंड यहां पे ओ टॉप 10 के बारे में
हम बात करने वाले हैं एंड एंड
दैट्ची ही गया होगा कि आज के मार्केट में
बग बाउंट हंटर्स की बग हंटर्स की इतनी
डिमांड है ना कि आप यकीन नहीं होगा किसी
भी सेक्टर से सबसे ज्यादा रेशियो है बग
हंटर्स बग हंटर्स की डिमांड की सबसे
ज्यादा रेशियो बग हंटर्स की डिमांड इतनी
ज्यादा है इतनी ज्यादा मतलब डेंजरस यह
डोमेन है और अगर इस डोमेन में आप रहते हो
तो आप फाइनेंशियलीईएक्सप्रेस
फाइनेंस इंडिपेंडेंट हो जाओगे क्योंकि
मैंने ऐसे देखा है ना यह जो बग बाउंट
हंटिंग यह जो डोमेन है लोगों की लाइफ को
चेंज करते हुए बट आपके दिमाग में ना यह
नहीं रखना है कि मुझे पैसे कमाने के लिए
सीरीज देखनी है सीखनी है यह दिमाग में मत
रखना कमा लोगे पैसे भी आएंगे बहुत अर्निंग
होगी बट यह सोच के मत करना कि मुझे पैसे
ही कमाने हैं ट्स व्हाई आई एम अर्निंग ट्स
व्हाई आई एम लर्निंग प्लीज यह मत करना
बाकी सब
करो चलिए अब मैंने आप सबको ट चैनल पर
बताया था कि आपको काली इंस्टॉल करके रखनी
है आज के सेशन में रिक्वायर्ड नहीं है बट
क्या आप में से कितने लोगों ने काली को
इंस्टॉल कर लिया मुझे बताइए जरा चैट में
बता दीजिए कितने लोगों ने काली को इंस्टॉल
कर लिया है वी एमवेयर या वर्चुअल बॉक्स
में किसी भी वर्चुअल मशीन में कितने लोगों
ने काली को इंस्टॉल किया है मुझे बताइए
चैट में जल्दी
से जल्दी बताइए शिव शिवम सर कशन बढ़ाने
वाले हैं बग बाउटी में मैं तो कंप्लीट
सिखाऊंगा आप सीख सकते हो तो अच्छी बात है
ना सीखो तो मुझे नहीं पता बट अगर आप
कंटिन्यू रहोगे तो आप इतना कुछ सीख लोगे
ना कि आपको फिर उसके बाद मेरी जरूरत नहीं
पड़ेगी आप खुद ही बहुत कुछ करने लगोगे ठीक
है एंड प्रो आप बन जाओगे यह श्यर रहो
तुम
ओके
ओके ओके तो काफी लोगों ने यस पैराट यस भी
आप कर सकते हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं हम काली
को लेकर चलने वाले हैं इसलिए मैंने काली
का पूछा पैरा टस भी कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम
नहीं नॉट एन इशू ठीक
है ओके काफी लोगों ने काली इंस्टॉल कर
लिया
है ट्स वेरी ग्रेट काफी अच्छा लगा मुझे
आपका यह रिस्पांस देके कि आपने काली
इंस्टॉल काफी लोगों ने किया हुआ है बहुत
अच्छा लगा बट स्टिल स्टिल स्टिल स्टिल
स्टिल ठीक है स्टिल अगर आपने नहीं किया है
जिन्होंने नहीं किया है ना काली को
इंस्टॉल आप जल्दी से कर लीजिए क्योंकि किस
सेशन में उसकी जरूरत पड़ जाए मुझे भी नहीं
पता है क्योंकि मैं प्री डिफाइंड कुछ
फिक्स करके नहीं करा रहा हूं ये पूरा
सीरीज जब जैसा आता जाएगा जब जैसे जो
स्टेप्स करने हैं वो करता जाऊंगा
जिन्होंने नहीं किया है डिक्स एडमी हमारे
वेयर के अंदर मैंने v एमवेयर के अंदर करा
है आप वर्चुअल बॉक्स के अंदर में भी सेम
तरीके से कर सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
तो सबसे पहले ये वीएम वेर वर्क स्टेशन है
इसको ओपन करोगे और इसमें मेरी काली जो है
वो इंस्टॉल्ड है यहां पे काली इंस्टॉल्ड
है और हां एक चीज एक चीज अगर आपके दिमाग
में यह चीज है ना कि बग बाउंट के लिए मुझे
अच्छी सिस्टम की कॉन्फिन ना भी हो तो भी
चलेगा तो यह निकाल दो एक अच्छी कॉन्फिन की
सिस्टम आपको चाहिए दो ऑप्शन है आपके पास
या तो एक अच्छी कॉन्फिन की सिस्टम हो या
या तो आप क्लाउड का यूज़ करो यूज अ क्लाउड
क्लाउड के लिए आप
amazon-in यूज़ कर सकते हो
अच्छी पीसी चाहिए एक अच्छा लैपटॉप चाहिए
अच्छे कॉन्फिन की चाहिए अगर आपके पास
अच्छी कॉन्फिन की लैपटॉप है तो आपको बग
बाउंट जो आप करोगे ना हंटिंग तो आपको मजा
भी आएगा क्योंकि बहुत सिस्टम पे ना एफर्ट
लगता है सिस्टम के प्रोसेसर प एफर्ट लगता
है ग्राफिक्स पे एफर्ट लगता है तो आपको वो
चाहिए अगर आपके पास नहीं है तो एक अच्छी
कॉन्फिन की लैपटॉप आप लो या तो अपग्रेड
करो अपने लैपटॉप को सीधी सी बात है अगर
मेरे लैपटॉप की कॉन्फिन की अगर बात करोगे
तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं यहां पे
प्रॉपर्टीज प चलता हूं मैं
आपको सॉरी
सॉरी ओके मेरा जो लैपटॉप है यह i7
प्रोसेसर के साथ आता है बेस क्लॉक स्पीड
इसकी 2.6 गह की है जो कि 4.5 गह तक बूस्ट
हो जाता है जब भी इसकी रिक्वायरमेंट होती
है यह बेचारा ऑटोमेटिक बूस्ट हो जाता है
इसकी कैपेसिटी है उतनी 16gb की इसमें बेस
रम आई हुई थी मैंने एक और रम स्लॉट में एक
16gb का और डाल दिया 32gb का इसको मैंने
कर दिया अब 32gb पे ये कुछ ज्यादा ही
स्मूथ चल रहा है पहले 16gb पे भी ठीक चलता
था बट कई बार लैग भी होते थे जब मल्टीपल
चीजें ओपन होती थी बट अब 32gb पे ना जब
मैं तीन चार पांच चीजें भी ओपन कर रहा हूं
फिर भी बढ़िया चल रहा है तो r का बहुत
ज्यादा यहां पे रिक्वायरमेंट होता है बहुत
ज्यादा रोल प्ले करता है रम भी ग्राफिक्स
के साथ-साथ यहां पे अगर मैं बात करूं
ग्राफिक्स की तो
nv12 का ग्राफिक्स कार्ड है मेरा जो कि
काम चल जाता है उससे कोई प्रॉब्लम ज्यादा
नहीं आती है ठीक है ws1 हमारा चल रहा है
64 बिट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यहां पे है एंड यह
कॉन्फिन है बट ये मैं आपको नहीं बोल रहा
कि आपको 32gb का ही रम चाहिए आप 8gb रम से
भी काम चला सकते हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
वही है मल्टीपल चीजें ओपन करोगे तो थोड़ा
लैग होगा बट हमें अभी स्टार्टिंग में
मल्टीपल चीजें नहीं ओपन करनी है एक दो
चीजें से काम चल जाएगा 16gb है और भी बेटर
है 32gb है तो बहुत बढ़िया है ठीक है तो
आप अपने बजट के अकॉर्डिंग अपनी सिस्टम की
जो अपग्रेडेशन है वो कर लीजिएगा अगर आपके
पास सिस्टम नहीं है लैपटॉप नहीं है तो
लैपटॉप में इन्वेस्ट कीजिए क्योंकि लैपटॉप
में इन्वेस्ट करना कभी भी कभी भी आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल ही रहेगा ये बात लिख के रखी और
लैपटॉप आप बार-बार नहीं लेते हर 6 महीने
पे लैपटॉप थोड़ी ना चेंज करोगे यार हर 6
महीने पे कौन लैपटॉप चेंज करता है लैपटॉप
एक बार लोगे कुछ टाइम तक चलाओगे तो एक
अच्छी लैपटॉप लो थोड़ा वेट करके लो लेकिन
अच्छी लैपटॉप लो अगर बजट नहीं है थोड़ा
वेट करो बजट बनाओ पेरेंट्स के पास अगर बजट
उतना नहीं हो पा रहा है तो उनको ज्यादा
फोर्स मत करो ठीक है अपना बजट थोड़ा बनाओ
धीरे-धीरे वेट करो जब उनके पास हो जाए तो
लो और तब अच्छा लैपटॉप एक लो ठीक है
दैट्ची अभी फिलहाल हम ज्यादा कुछ इस पर
बात नहीं करेंगे बट v एमवेयर वर्चुअल
बॉक्स में कौन सा यूज करना है यह टोटली
आपके ऊपर डिपेंड करता है वर्चुअल बॉक्स जो
है वो कंप्लीट फ्री सॉफ्टवेयर है अगर आप
डाउनलोड करना चाहे तो वर्चुअल बॉक्स ऐसे
करेंगे तो इसकी जो ऑफिशियल वेबसाइट है इस
पे आप आ जाते हैं एंड यहां से आप आएंगे तो
डाउनलोड वर्चुअल बॉक्स पे जब आप जाएंगे तो
यहां
wss4j चेंज आता है वो आप करके काली को
इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं मैं ऑलवेज v ए वेर को
प्रेफर करता हूं क्योंकि मैं हमेशा इसी को
यूज करता आया हूं
दैट्ची कीजिएगा यहां पे इसके ऑफिशियल
वेबसाइट पे आप चले जाइएगा जब आप यहां
आएंगे तो यहां पे व स्शन प्र डाउनलोड करने
का आएगा एंड यहां
तो ये कंप्लीट फ्री है व स्शन प्र पेड
वर्जन है प्लेयर उसका एकदम फ्री वर्जन है
इसमें दो-तीन ऑप्शन मतलब कुछ चीजें आपको
नहीं मिलेंगी फीचर जैसे वर्चुअल नेटवर्क
एडिटर का ऑप्शन नहीं मिलता आपको स्क्रीन अ
स्नैपशॉट नहीं ले पाएंगे आप एक दो फीचर है
बट इन फीचर से आपका कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ने
वाला है तो अगर आपको प्रो नहीं यूज़ करना
है तो बिल्कुल इसका एब्सलूट फ्री वर्जन आप
vmware.com आपको फ्री अल्टरनेटिव भी बता
दिया 2gb रम है कुछ नहीं होने वाला है 2gb
रम से भैया 2gb रम मोबाइल में आते हैं
क्या भाई एक बात बताओ यार तुम 2gb रम बोल
रहे हो 2gb रम मोबाइल में नहीं आते आजकल
तो यार आजकल तो मतलब मोबाइल में भी कम से
कम 4gb रम आ रहा है 8gb रम अब तो हो चुके
हैं 16 16gb पज भी आ रहा है प्लीज अपग्रेड
योर रम यार प्लीज इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट अ सर 8gb रम i5 चलेगा चलेगा
चलेगा 8gb रम 256gb i5 चलेगा बिल्कुल
चलेगा ग्राफिक्स कार्ड नहीं है थोड़ा सा
वहां पे तो थोड़ा वो नेगेटिव पॉइंट है बट
स्टिल काम चल जाएगा अभी आपका i9 ये देखो
यहां पे
i9
64gb ओ हो हो 60 36 3600 गह का इसका इनका
स्पीड है ये एंड 10gb का ग्राफी इन्होंने
पूरा कंपैटिबल वो करवाया हुआ है बहुत
बढ़िया कॉन्फिन है आपका तो मस्त चलेगा न 5
चलेगा
बढ़िया बिल्कुल बिल्कुल अपलोड होगी टेंशन
ना लो ठीक है तो यह आपको काम कर लेना है
यह चीज आपको करके रखनी है चलिए अब यहां पर
हम अपने काली का काली की बात हमने कर ली
काली को आपको इंस्टॉल करके रखना है अब बात
करते हैं गाइस कि सबसे पहला स्टेप आपको
क्या लेना है सबसे फर्स्ट स्टेप आपका क्या
होना चाहिए मैं यहां पर आपके लिए एक
वेबसाइट ओपन कर रहा हूं देखिएगा यह
वेबसाइट आपकी लाइफ चेंज करेगी सो जस्ट की
फोकस
यर यह वेबसाइट है
हैक me.com यहां पे मैंने अपना एक अकाउंट
बनाया है यह अ मतलब ओल्ड अकाउंट है एक
बहुत पहले का तो यह अकाउंट जो है ट्राई
हैक मी का है दिस अकाउंट इज ऑफ ट्राई हैक
मी ट्राई हैक म अकाउंट है तो यहां पे क्या
होता है भैया ट्रक के अकाउंट पे व्हाट
हैपेंस हियर यहां पे आपको इसक me.com को
बुकमार्क कर लेना है यहां पे बुकमार्क कर
लीजिए इसको दिमाग में डाल लीजिए और और हो
सके तो इसका सब्सक्रिप्शन लीजिए मंथली
बेसिस वाला अब सब्सक्रिप्शन तो बहुत महंगा
इसका मिलता है है ना सब्सक्रिप्शन ट्रा
हैक में का पर मंथ का काफी कॉस्टली हो
जाता है एक स्टूडेंट के लिए काफी कॉस्टली
है तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं जस्ट आप आप
कहीं से अरेंज भी कर सकते हो देख लो अगर
कोई अकाउंट अरेंज हो जाए तो मेरी बात अगर
आपको समझ में आ रही है तो अच्छी बात है आप
अकाउंट अरेंज कर सकते हो एंड यू कैन यू
कैन देन स्टार्ट यूजिंग द सब्सक तो आप
सब्सक्रिप्शन इसका लो यह मैं आपको रिकमेंड
करूंगा इसका सब्सक्रिप्शन लेना जो है ना
वो आपके लिए बेनिफिशियल ही होगा आपके लिए
कभी भी वो रिग्रेट नहीं करने देगा आपको कि
आपने सब्सक्रिप्शन क्यों ले लिया ये बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है ट्राई हैक मी बहुत
बहुत बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट हम बहुत सारे
ट्राई हैक के लैब्स को भी इंक्लूड करने
वाले हैं इस पूरी सीरीज में पोट्स फिगर के
लैब्स को इंक्लूड करने वाले हैं रियल
टारगेट प हंट करने वाले हैं जो कि ओपन बग
बाउटी बग क्राउड और हैकर वन से चूज हम
करने वाले हैं इस पूरी बक बाउटी सीरीज में
ठीक हैट्स इट ओके
ओके ट्स दिस दिस दिस ट्राय हैक मी अब यहां
पर मैं आपको बता देता हूं ट्राय हैक मी
में यहां पर वैसे तो जब आप लर्न पे जाएंगे
ना ट्रायक मी पे सर्च पे जाएंगे इसमें आके
आपको लॉग इन कर लेना है आपको एक अपने
google3 से ज्यादा लैब्स आपको मिल जाएंगे
जो कि बिल्कुल फ्री है कोई पैसा आपको नहीं
देना है तो आप यह कर तो सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है बट क्या है ना कि फ्री
वाले जब आप करोगे ना लैब्स को तोय अलग-अलग
टॉपिक्स पर आपको मिलेंगे लैब्स बट आपका व
कांसेप्ट तो क्लियर है नहीं तो आपको एक
पाथ को फॉलो करना है एंड व पाथ क्या है वो
पाथ कैसे फॉलो करना है आपको आपको लर्न पर
जाना है आपको लर्न प यहां पर चले जाना है
यहां पर लर्न प आप आएंगे तो आपको एक
मिलेगा लर्निंग पाथ यह लर्निंग पाथ आपको
मिलेगा लर्निंग पाथ में आपको इंट्रोडक्शन
टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी सबसे पहले कंप्लीट
करनी है उसके बाद आप प्री सिक्योरिटी को
कंप्लीट कर सकते हैं जूनियर पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर फिर आता है सब कुछ मतलब ये एक वे
में चलना है मैं अभी इसलिए इसलिए डिटेल
नहीं जा रहा क्योंकि हम इसको करने वाले
हैं हम इसको करेंगे हम इसको जब जब हमारे
पास जो जो रिक्वायरमेंट आएगी ना हम उस
रिक्वायरमेंट को फुलफिल करने वाले हैं हम
उस सब चीजों को करने वाले हैं तो आपको
ज्यादा इसकी टेंशन नहीं लेनी है बस मैं
आपको एक ओवरव्यू दे रहा हूं तो कि आप
नेक्स्ट जब क्लासेस होंगी नेक्स्ट क्लासेस
से ना आप इन चीज को कंप्लीट करके रखिएगा
ट्रा हैक में पे लॉग इन करके अकाउंट बना
के रखिएगा काली को इंस्टॉल करके रखना है
आपको और जो चीजें भी बताऊंगा वह काम भी
आपको करना है ठीक है करना है तो करना है
दूसरा
आपको बग
क्राउड इस पे जाना
है बग क्राउड पे एंड हैकर
वन इस पे जाना है बक क्राउड एंड हैकर वन
तो आपको बग क्राउड पे आना है एंड यहां पे
यहां पे ये जो आपको दिख रहा है हैकर लॉगिन
इन हैकर लॉगिन पे आप जाइएगा यहां पे हैकर
लॉगिन यहां
पे ओके ये अ ओके मैं लॉग आउट कर देता हूं
ये एक्सपायर का बता रहा है एक्सपायर हो
गया है ठीक है मैं लॉग आउट कर देता
हूं यहां पे आप आएंगे तो आप क्या है आप एक
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर है रिसर्चर पे क्लिक
कर दीजिएगा एंड यहां पे आप क्या करेंगे आप
एक अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लेंगे क्रिएट एन
अकाउंट पे क्लिक करके जब आप क्रिएट एन
अकाउंट पे क्लिक करेंगे तो आप साइन अप कर
सकते हैं बक क्राउड पे एज अ रिसर्चर आप
अपने अकाउंट बना लीजिएगा लॉगइन कर लीजिएगा
हैकर वन प भी सेम वैसे ही कीजिएगा हैकर वन
प भी क्या करना है आपको सेम एज अ रिसर्चर
जो है आपको क्या करना है साइन अप कर लेना
है क्या कर लेना है क्रिएट हैकर न अकाउंट
प जाके आपको साइन अप कर लेना है एंड हैकर
ऑन पे अकाउंट बना लेना है तो यहां पे आप
आई एम हैकर कर दीजिएगा एंड यहां पे आई एम
रिसर्चर करके बना लीजिएगा इन दोनों प भी
अकाउंट आपको बना लेनी है ठीक है यह काम
आपको कर लेना है
चलिए ओके यह सबसे सबसे ज्यादा सबसे ज्यादा
पॉपुलर बग बाउंट
प्लेटफॉर्म सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर बग बाउटी
प्लेटफॉर्म जहां पर प्रोग्राम्स लिस्टेड
है प्रोग्राम लिस्टेड है का मतलब मैं क्या
बोल रहा हूं जैसे कि देखो बकरा कॉ पर हम
चलते हैं देखो
देखो प्रोग्राम्स पर चलते
हैं प्रोग्राम्स पर चलते हैं एंड यहां पर
आ जाते हैं
ओके अब यहां पर यह जो प्रोग्राम्स आपको
दिख रहे हैं ना यहां पर जो आपको प्रोग्राम
दिख रहे हैं यह प्रोग्राम्स वैसे हैं यह
वह कंपनीज है जिन्होंने आपको परमिशन दे
रखी है कि आप आओ हमारे पे हंट करो एंड
हमारी अलग-अलग एसेट्स में वनबिल फाइंड
करके दिखाओ और उसके बदले में हम आपको पे
करेंगे या पॉइंट्स देंगे रिवार्ड्स देंगे
व्हाट एवर वी हैव द कैपेसिटी ऑफ ठीक है तो
यह सारे वही कंपनीज हैं इसमें आपको कुछ
बहुत पॉपुलर कंपनीज भी मिल जाएंगे जैसे आप
देखिए यहां पे आप नीचे स्क्रॉल करते
आइए
पॉपुलर जो आपको पता हो हब स्पॉट अगर आपको
पता हो तो काफी लोग को पता होगा वन
पासवर्ड वन शॉपिंग कार्ड क्रेडिट कर्मा
यहां
पे चलिए इसको मैं पेज टू पे चल के लेके
चलता हूं आपको वहां पर भी और भी यहां प
आपको दिख जाएंगे बहुत सारे आपके जान पहचान
की कंपनीज मिल जाएंगी अगर आपको नहीं पता
यर
जी रैम i5 ठीक है काम काम चलेगा काम चलेगा
प्रैक्टिकल भी होगा ना यार तुम लोग यही तो
दिक्कत है घबराया मत करो काम रिलैक्स
घबराना नहीं है कुछ भी हो जाए घबराना नहीं
है रिलैक्स रहना है टेंशन नहीं लेनी है
रिलैक्स रहना है सब आएगा पहले ही एक ही
सेशन में सब चीजें कैसे बताया जा सकता है
तो जैसे जैसे सेशंस आगे बढ़ते जाएंगे फुल
प्रैक्टिकल ही है टेंशन नहीं लेनी है थरी
वो थोड़ा बहुत ही है
इसमें ओके
हां रियल से लॉग इन कर लो जैसे लॉग इन
करना है कर लो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं आपने
रियल ईमेल आईडी रियल से कर लो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं आप सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर हो यार आप एक
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर हो आप कोई आप कोई वो
इल्लीगल काम नहीं कर रहे हो यू आर डूइंग
लीगल थिंग दिस ऑल आर लीगल थिंग्स हां एक
बात जिनके दिमाग में ऐसा नहीं है ऐसा मत
रखना कि बग बाउंट एक इलीगल चीज है नहीं
कंप्लीट लीगल चीज है तो यू आर डूइंग अ
लीगल थिंग यू कैन यूज योर ओन नेम एंड ऑल
जो भी है यूज कर सकते हो कोई बात नहीं कुछ
लोग यूज नहीं करते हैं आप भी अगर चाहो तो
ना करो कोई बात नहीं बट करोगे कोई कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं ठीक है कोई भी प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है
ओके सर आपकी क्वालिफिकेशन क्या है
क्वालिफिकेशन मेरी है मैंने कंप्यूटर
साइंस बीटेक करा है उसके बाद बीटेक के बाद
मैंने सोचा कुछ छोड़ ही दूं है ना
चलो सो गट इट इतना समझ में आ गया होगा
आपको अब यहां पे चलते हैं बग बाउटी
प्लेटफॉर्म्स के बारे में हमने समझ लिया
हमने जान लिया अब आते हैं कि बग बाउंट को
शुरू करने से पहले रेकन न भी शुरू करने से
पहले सबसे पहला सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट चीज क्या
है दैट इज ओस टॉप 10 दैट इज ओस टॉप 10
क्यों क्यों भाई ओस टॉप 10 क्यों चाहिए ये
हमें इसकी हमें क्यों रिक्वायरमेंट है इस
इस चीज की क्यों रिक्वायरमेंट है ओस टॉप
10 है क्या चलिए चलते हैं
ओस टॉप
10 इनको ओपन कर लेते हैं
और इसके बारे में थोड़ा सा जानते हैं कि
है क्या ये द ओस टॉप 10 इज अ स्टैंडर्ड
अवेयरनेस डॉक्यूमेंट फॉर डेवलपर्स एंड वेब
एप्लीकेशन सिक्योरिटी इट रिप्रेजेंट्स अ
ब्रॉड कंसेंसस अबाउट द मोस्ट क्रिटिकल
सिक्योरिटी रिस्क टू वेब एप्लीकेशन अब ओप
जो है ना ठीक है ओप एक कम्युनिटी है ठीक
है फाउंडेशन है कम्युनिटी है इन्होंने
क्या किया सोचा कि हम क्यों ना एक टाइम
टाइम पे
ईयर वाइज एक लिस्ट निकाले ऐसे व बिलिटी का
जो सबसे
ज्यादा पाए जाते हैं वेब एप्लीकेशन में
सबसे ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल होते हैं एंड
उन्हीं को फाइंड करना ज्यादा बेटर है बाकी
अदर व बिलिटी से अगर उनको फाइंड किया जाता
है किसी रिसर्चर के तरफ से तो उसको वैलिड
माना जाएगा एंड उसको जो है मिटिगेट किया
जाएगा बाय द डेल बा कंपनी तो इन्होंने एक
लिस्ट बनाई 10 10 वने बिलिटी की
लिस्ट 10 लेबिलिटी की लिस्ट बनाई या 10
कैटेगरी में डिवाइड कर दिया यू कैन से
लेबिलिटी को 10 कैटेगरी में वने बिलिटी को
हालाकि टी देर लट ऑफ टी उनको 10 कैटेगरी
में डिवाइड कर दिया एंड उसी को हम ओस टॉप
10 बोलते हैं इसको रिप्रेजेंट कैसे करते
हैं a01 a02 a03 a04 a05 इस तरीके से इनको
रिप्रेजेंट किया जाता है a06 a07 a08 a09
a01 दिस वे इट इज बीइंग
रिप्रेजेंटेड अब यहां दिख रहा होगा आपको
2017 और यहां राइट में आपको दिख रहा होगा
2021 अब ये क्या है भैया तो मैंने बताया
ना ईयर वाइज आते हैं कुछ चेंजेज होने हो
कुछ चेंजेज किए हो तो फिर नेक्स्ट वाले जब
पब्लिश होंगे नेक्स्ट ईयर का तो उसमें वो
चेंजेज ये रिफ्लेक्ट कर देते हैं अब जैसे
कि 2017 में टॉप 10 में जो कैटेगरी थी वह
इंजेक्शन थी ब्रोकन ऑथेंटिकेशन थी
सेंसिटिव डाटा एक्सपोजर थी एक्सएमएल एंड
एक्सटर्नल एंटिटीज थी ब्रोकन एक्सेस
कंट्रोल थी सिक्योरिटी मिस कन्फेशन थी
एक्सेसेस थी इस तरह की लिस्ट थी बट 2021
में इसमें थोड़ा चेंज किया गया चेंज क्या
किया गया ब्रोकेन एक्सेस कंट्रोल जो फिफ्थ
नंबर पे था उसको फर्स्ट नंबर पर लाया गया
यानी यह ज्यादा डेंजरस हो सकता है इसकी
प्रा टी को मतलब प्रायोरिटी को अच्छी मतलब
ऊपर कर दी गई एक तरह से यू कैन से यू कैन
से इसको ऊपर इसको थोड़ा सा अपग्रेड किया
गया उसको ऊपर लेकर आया गया स्टेप को सेकंड
पे क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलर को लाया गया
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलर को लाया गया किसकी
जगह पे सेंसिटिव डाटा आपके ब्रोकन
ऑथेंटिकेशन की जगह पे सेकंड पे पहले सेकंड
पे क्या था ब्रोकन ऑथेंटिकेशन था 2017 में
अब सेकंड पे क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलियर है
थर्ड पे इंजेक्शन है फोर्थ में एक नई चीज
लाई गई नया कैटेगरी लाया गया जिसको हमने
बोला इनसिक्योर डिजाइन हम सबके बारे में
जानेंगे सबके बारे में समझेंगे एक एक करके
समझेंगे टेंशन नहीं लेनी है कि भैया यह
क्या है क्योंकि इसको अगर आपने नहीं समझा
आपने आपने बहुत बेसिक चीज नहीं समझी ना तो
आपको नहीं समझ में आएगा एंड आपको यही तो
पढ़ना है आपको वनबिल तो आपको पता होंगी बट
वो सारी वलने बिलिटी इन 10 कैटेगरी में
आती है ये आपको पता था क्या आपको पता है
आप जितने भी बग बाउंट हंटिंग में बग
हंटिंग में जो भी वलने बिलिटी आप देखते
हैं ना मोस्ट ऑफ देम फॉल्स इन दीज 10
कैटेगरी मोस्ट ऑफ देम नॉट एवरी वलने
बिलिटी बट मोस्ट ऑफ देम फॉल्स इन दिस
कैटेगरी जो भी मेन वलने बिलिटी है इस
कैटेगरी में फॉल करते हैं आप सबको पता था
ये
चीज आप सबको पता था प्लीज लेट मी नो प्लीज
लेट मी नो हां भाई इंग्लिश थोड़ी वीक है
सही बोले इंग्लिश थोड़ी वीक है थोड़ी वीक
है बट काम चलाऊ चल जाता है मतलब फॉरेन
रेंज जाना हो तो वहां पर समझ भी सकते हैं
और बा सामने वाले को समझाया भी जा सकता है
बाकी हिंदुस्तान के हैं तो हिंदी हिंदी
भाई प्रायोरिटी है अपनी बताइए आपको यह चीज
पता था
क्या प्लीज लेट मी नो ओ टॉप 10 के बारे
में पता था आप लोगों को कितने लोगों को
पता था बताइए मुझे जल्दी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू
ऑलरेडी
नोई पता था बहुत
बढ़िया
youtube0 वीडियो एंड दिस आर लीगल वीडियोस
इसके लिए कोई टेंशन नहीं है चलो बहुत
बढ़िया अब यह मुझे बताओ पता तो है आप सबको
क्या आप सबने ये a1 से a10 तक की जो यह
कैटेगरी हैं उसको डिटेल में स्टडी करा है
क्या पहले किसी ने भी स्टडी करा है डिटेल
में डिटेल में स्टडी करा है
आपने मुझे पता है 90 पर लोगों ने नहीं करा
है 100% तो नहीं बोलूंगा 90 पर लोगों ने
नहीं करा होगा
इसको डिटेल में स्टडी राइट यहां देख लो
काफी लोगों ने नहीं करा है राइट हम बहुत
डिटेल में पढ़ेंगे और जानेंगे हर कैटेगरी
में किस तरह से क्या-क्या चीजें इसमें काम
करती है कैसे काम करती है सारा कुछ हम
जानने वाले हैं सारा कुछ ए टू
जड ठीक है बढ़िया
चलिए सो ओ टॉप 10 के बारे में हम सारा कुछ
जानेंगे अब अब बात करते हैं गाइस जब ओस
टॉप 10 के बारे में आप सीखो तो जब आप सीख
लोगे ना तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि बग्स
को कैसे कैटेगरी करना है कैसे आपको हंट
करना है कैसे आपको एक एक स्टेप वाइज चलना
है आगे प्रोसेस क्या है अब जब तुम बग
हंटिंग करोगे ना अब तुम मुझे बताओ तुम
मुझे बताओ एक क्वेश्चन सबसे है यहां पर
जितने भी प्रेजेंट है सबसे एक क्वेश्चन है
मेरा सबसे एवरीवन प्लीज प्लीज लिसन माय
क्वेश्चन अगर आपको बग हंटिंग करनी है आप
बग हंटिंग कर रहे हो अब थाउजेंड्स ऑफ बग्स
है हंड्रेड्स ऑफ बग्स है आप कैसे अपने आप
उसको मैनेज कैसे करोगे कैसे मैनेज करोगे
कि भाई किस पे हंट करना है किस पे हंट कर
लिया किस पे हंट करना बाकी है कैसे करेंगे
क्या करेंगे हाउ यू विल मैनेज इस चीज को
मैनेज करने के लिए चेकलिस्ट होती है एक इस
चीज को मैनेज करने के लिए देयर आर
चेकलिस्ट जो हर सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर हर
हंटर का अपना बनाया होता है या बनाना
चाहिए अगर नहीं बना तो बनाना पड़ेगा नहीं
है तो बनाना पड़ेगा एंड मैं आपको बताऊंगा
कैसे बनाना है वो भी बताऊंगा उसकी भी
टेंशन राइट तो चेकलिस्ट आपको बनानी पड़ती
है एक ऑलरेडी मेड चेकलिस्ट जो है ना आपके
पास मैं आपको बता देता हूं ओस की चेकलिस्ट
एक ऑलरेडी मेड आपको मिल जाएगी इंटरनेट पर
आप उसको भी यूज कर सकते हैं बट आई विल
रिकमेंड ओस
चेकलिस्ट बट आपको मैं रिकमेंड करूंगा
हालाकि यह आप देख सकते हैं एंड दिस वन
आपको मैं रिकमेंड करूंगा कि आप खुद की चेक
लिस्ट बनाइए नॉट गो विथ ऑलरेडी मेड
चेकलिस्ट जैसे ये एक चेकलिस्ट है ओस के
तरफ से ये जो डिफॉल्ट चेकलिस्ट आपको यहां
पे दिख रही होगी ये चेकलिस्ट ये भी एक
चेकलिस्ट है बट मैं आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा
गो विथ योर ओन कस्टम चेकलिस्ट या फिर गिट
हप पे आप आएंगे तो यहां पे आपको एप
चेकलिस्ट एक गिट हप रिपोजिटरी पे मिलेगी
एंड आप जब यहां पे अ चेकलिस्ट ड एक्सए
फाइल को क्लिक करेंगे तो ये डाउनलोड हो
जाएगा राइट ये डाउनलोड हो जाएगा चलिए मैं
आपको एक चीज दिखाता हूं मैं एक्सलस पे इस
पे क्लिक करता हूं लेट्स ट्राई टू
डाउनलोड डाउनलोड करता हूं
मैं ओके यह डाउनलोड नहीं हो
रहा यह डाउनलोड नहीं हो रहा है राइट अ एक
काम करता हूं मैं व्यू र पे क्लिक करके
ओपन लिंक की न्यू टैप करता हूं एंड लेट्स
सी देखो यह गब से ये डाउनलोड नहीं हो
रहा जी बिल्कुल बिल्कुल महाकाल गेमर जी
बिल्कुल अपलोड होगी टेंशन नहीं लेना आपको
ये यह डाउनलोड क्यों नहीं हो रहा है ये
एक्सल एस फाइल है एक्सेल की फाइल है मैंने
क्लिक किया इंटरनेट बिल्कुल काम कर रहा है
लेट्स पिंग इट लेट्स पिंग इट पिंग
google.com एंड इट्स पिंग वाओ ग्रेट अ
पिंग अ github.com एंड इट्स पिंग मतलब गिब
भी काम कर रहा है आपका सब कुछ काम कर रहा
है स्टिल इट्स नॉट डाउनलोडिंग व्हाई एनी
रीजन फॉर इट किसी को पता है किसी को पता
है ये अरे डीसीएसपी वाले नहीं बोलेंगे
जो हमारे लाइव ट्रेनिंग वाले हैं वो मत
बोलो प्लीज बाकी लोगों को बोलने दो मुझे
पता है आप लोगों को पता
है मुझे पता है आप लोगों को पता है
राइट
तो अब चलो अब यहां पे यह ना डाउनलोड होने
का रीजन काफी लोगों को नहीं पता होगा शायद
नहीं पता होगा मैं सेम
सेम ठीक है मैं यहां पे मैं यहां पे सेम
चीज ना कॉपी करता हूं हू मैं सेम चीज मैं
अपने
सिस्टम वाइज डीएनएस चेंज करना है तो
सिस्टम वाइज कर सकते हैं जैसे कि मान लो
मुझे इस पर्टिकुलर ब्राउजर में अ ये
डाउनलोड नहीं हो अगर हो रहा हो तो जैसे आप
सेटिंग में जाओगे सेटिंग में कम के सेटिंग
में जाओगे यहां पे आप आओगे प्राइवेसी एंड
सिक्योरिटी पे यहां पे आप नीचे आओगे तो
यहां पे एक सिक्योरिटी का ऑप्शन मिलेगा इस
पे आप आ जाइएगा नीचे आइएगा नीचे आइएगा तो
यहां पे आपका डिफॉल्ट जो
करेंगे ना तो ये डाउनलोड नहीं होगा
चलो अभी तो ये सेटिंग रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हुई
है लेकिन ये डाउनलोड नहीं होगा कई केसेस
में नहीं होते हैं बट अगर आपके केसेस में
हो रहे हैं तो अच्छी बात है नहीं हो रहे
हैं तो आप एक
चले जाएं एंड इसी को यूज करें आप पब्लिक
डीएनएस को यूज ना करें दैट इज नॉट सिक्योर
इनफ क्यों डीएनएस आप अगर पब्लिक यूज करते
हैं तो आपकी डाटा मे भी रिस्की हो सकती है
एंड वो नॉट सिक्योर के कैटेगरी में आ
जाएगा तो आपको जब काम हो तब आप कीजिए इन
ब्राउजर एंड आपका काम खत्म हो जाए कहानी
को खत्म वहीं पे कर देना है आपको ठीक है
दैट्ची कुछ ऐसा चीज हो रहा है तो आप
डीएनएस को चेंज कर सकते हैं तो सिस्टम
लेवल के लिए आपको कंट्रोल पैनल ओपन कर
लेना है यहां पे आपको जाना है नेटवर्क एंड
शेयरिंग सेंटर पे एंड यहां पे आपको अपने
जो भी आपका कनेक्शन चल रहा है उसपे आप चले
जाइएगा यहां पे आप प्रॉपर्टीज पे चले
जाइएगा प्रॉपर्टीज पे आके आप टीसीपी आईपी
4 इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन फर वाली जो
ऑप्शन है इस पे आप चले जाइएगा ठीक है ठीक
है इस पे आप चले जाइएगा एंड यहां पे आप
आएंगे तो यूज द फॉलोइंग डीएनएस सर्वर का
ऑप्शन मिलेगा इस पे आप आ जाइएगा एंड यहां
प्रेफर डीएनएस सर्वर के ऑप्शन में आप आप
के ऊपर थे तो ये चेकलिस्ट है अगर मैं इसकी
एक्सेल फाइल आपको ओपन करके दिखाऊं तो लेट
मी ओपन कैसा दिखता है ये रही ओ की
चेकलिस्ट है आपकी ये चेकलिस्ट है पूरी
यहां पे ये एक्सेल फाइल है कुछ इस तरीके
से आपकी चेकलिस्ट ये दिख रही है ये ऑलरेडी
मेड चेकलिस्ट है तो आपको इसमें मेहनत नहीं
करनी है जैसे कि अब देखो यहां पे ये
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग की चेकलिस्ट है दूसरे
पेज पे आप आओगे तो ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन एंड
डेप्लॉय मैनेजमेंट टेस्टिंग है तीसरे पे
आओगे आइडेंटिटी मैनेजमेंट टेस्टिंग है
चौथे पे आओगे ऑथेंटिकेशन टेस्टिंग करने के
ऑथराइजेशन टेस्टिंग करने के सेशन
मैनेजमेंट के टेस्टिंग के करने के डेटा
वैलिडेशन टेस्टिंग करने ये बहुत डिटेल में
बहुत ही बहुत ही डिटेल में ये चेकलिस्ट
आपके दिए गए हैं लेकिन जिनको नहीं नहीं बन
पा रहा ना जिसे चेकलिस्ट वो यूज कर लो बट
मैं आपको रिकमेंड करूंगा खुद की चेकलिस्ट
बनाओ एक एक्सेल के अंदर
में स्प्रेडशीट के अंदर में ठीक है खुद का
एंड वो कैसे बनाओगे आप सबसे पहले लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स को निकालो ऐसे बग्स जो
बहुत छोटे-छोटे बग्स होते हैं बट बहुत ही
बहुत ही ज्यादा यूजफुल होते हैं किसी का
कंपनी के लिए छोटे-छोटे उन बक्स को ना अगर
तुम चेन अप कर दोगे उसको और भी चेन करके
उसको और बड़ा बना सकते हो तो वो और ज्यादा
इंपैक्टफुल हो जाती है उससे ज्यादा
बाउंटीज उससे ज्यादा आपको रिवॉर्ड मिलने
के चांसेस बढ़ जाते हैं अब जैसे यहां पे
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग में क्या है पहला
कंडक्ट सर्च इंजन डिस्कवरी रिकॉन सेंस फॉर
इंफॉर्मेशन लीकेज ऑब्जेक्टिव में यहां पे
टूल क्या यूज कर सकते हो जीएचडीबी रिकन
एनजी शोडाउन ये यूज कर सकते हैं
फिंगरप्रिंट करना है आपको वेब सर्वर का
फिंगरप्रिंटिंग करना है उसका वर्जन उसका
टाइप आपको बताना है कौन सा सर्वर चल रहा
है यह सब पता करना है उसके लिए वेपराइजर
निकटो का यूज कर सकते हो ए मैप का भी यूज
कर सकते हो फिर रिव्यू करना है वेब सर्वर
के मेटा फाइल्स को इंफॉर्मेशन लीकेज के
लिए आपको मेटा फाइल्स को रिव्यू करना है
उसके लिए आप कर्ल का यूज कर सकते हो बब
सूट का यूज कर सकते हो उसके बाद आपको नरेट
करना है एप्लीकेशंस कौन-कौन से चल रहे है
ये पूरी चेकलिस्ट है तो इस तरीके से
चेकलिस्ट को फॉलो जैसे अगर आपने चेकलिस्ट
को कर दिया मान लो आपने चेकलिस्ट कर लिया
अब यहां पे आपका है स्टेटस नॉट स्टार्टेड
नॉट स्टार्टेड इस पे ये क्या आपका नॉट
स्टार्टेड है ये आपका जो स्टेटस है इसको
जब आपका हो जाए तो इसको स्टार्टेड कर
दीजिएगा जब कंप्लीट हो जाए तो कंप्लीट कर
दीजिएगा तो आप एक ट्रैक कर पाएंगे कि
कौन-कौन सी वल एबिलिटीज कौन-कौन से
स्टेप्स आपने कर लिए हैं चेकलिस्ट का बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंस है बहुत ज्यादा अब
जैसे-जैसे आप आगे बढ़ते जाओगे सीखते जाओगे
ना वैसे-वैसे आप चेकलिस्ट बनाते जाओगे एंड
जैसा कि मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला है आई
ऑलरेडी टोल्ड यू इसका लिंक दे दीजिए अरे
लिंक सर्च कर लो यार
सिंपल चलो मैं लिंक दे देता
हूं मैं लिंक दे देता हूं यहां पे चैट में
आई हैव गिवन द लिंक इन द चैट सेक्शन ऑफ
दिस चेकलिस्ट यू कैन फाइंड आउट ओके आपको
मिल जाएगी वहां
पे अब जैसे-जैसे सीखते जाओगे ना वले
एबिलिटीज को सीखते जाओगे वैसे-वैसे आप खुद
की चेकलिस्ट बनाते जाओगे बट मैंने आपको
पहले ही बोला ना हम सबसे पहले रेकन से
स्टार्ट करेंगे और रेकन में इतनी चीजें
करेंगे कि एक रेकन की चेकलिस्ट आपकी बहुत
बड़ी हो जाएगी बहुत बड़ी रेकन की चेकलिस्ट
हो जाएगी
बहुत कुछ आता है रिकन के अंदर में सब हम
स्टेप वाइज करेंगे एकएक चीज अलग-अलग टूल्स
के देखेंगे एकएक चीज लैब्स से भी देखेंगे
लाइव टारगेट प भी देखेंगे हर चीज करने
वाले हैं और यकीन मानिए अगर आपको बेनिफिट
ना मिले ना तो छोड़ देना देखना सीरीज बट
मैंने जैसा बोला 0 टू प्रो तो 0 टू प्रो
करना है बनना है तो बनना है मुझे बनाना है
तो बनाना है ये मतलब कफन बांध के मैं सर
पे आया हूं सोचो डायलग बट ये सच है यही
करना है मुझे अब यहां पे ट्राई हैक मी पे
एक चीज मैं और आपको बता देता हूं जिनको
नहीं पता होगा उनके लिए यह यूजफुल हो
जाएगी बहुत ज्यादा ट्राई हैक म को तुम जब
एक्सेस करोगे ना इस पे इसको जब चला रहे
होगे तो क्या करना होता है गाइस आप इसको
आप इसके एनवायरमेंट में कनेक्ट हो सकते हो
देखो ट्राई हैमी में क्या होता है ना अब
जैसे मान लो कोई लैब है कोई लैब है ठीक है
कोई भी लैब है कुछ भी है मान लो जूनियर
पटसन टेस्टर पे चलते हैं
यहां पे नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी पर चलते हैं
पैसिव रिकन सेंस वटी रिसर्च पे चलते हैं
मेटा एक्प्ट प चलते हैं कोई सा भी चल लो
मेटा एक्प्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन पे चलते हैं
कोई सा भी एक कोई सा भी एक ओपन कर लेते
हैं अब यहां पे ना लैब्स भी यहां पे आपको
लैब्स होते हैं ठीक है अलग-अलग लैब्स आपके
अलग-अलग टास्क आपके लैब के थ्रू आपको
प्रोवाइड किए जाते हैं इन लैब्स को करने
के लिए ना इन टास्क को करने के लिए आपको
क्या करना होता है आपको मशी को स्टार्ट
करना होता है एक कोई मशीन होती है इसको
स्टार्ट करना होता है ठीक है यह कुछ
फाइल्स है उससे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है आपको
यहां पर आपको स्टार्ट मशीन का एक ऑप्शन है
यह मशीन को स्टार्ट करना होता है अब ये
मशीन को जब स्टार्ट कर दोगे तो आपको एक
आईपी मिल जाती है ठीक है आईपी मिलती है अब
वो टारगेट का आपका आईपी हो जाता है अब उस
टारगेट के आईपी को आप एक्सेस कैसे कर सकते
हो दो तरीके से कर सकते हो एक तो आप इनका
इनबिल्ट अटैक बॉक्स यूज कर सकते हो या तो
जो कि पेड होते हैं जो कि प्रीमियम
सब्सक्रिप्शन के साथ ही आते हैं स्टार्ट
बॉक्स सॉरी अटैक बॉक्स पेड सब्सक्रिप्शन
नहीं है तो अटैक बॉक्स काम नहीं करेगा फिर
कैसे करेंगे भाई चलो मैं करके दिखाता हूं
मतलब एक एग्जांपल मैंने एक मशीन को
स्टार्ट किया जस्ट वेट ये मशीन स्टार्ट हो
गई मशीन स्टार्ट होते ही ये एक मिनट के
अंदर में मशीन की आईपी एड्रेस आपको
प्रोवाइड कर देगा देखो यहां पे ये टाइमर
चल रही होगी 53 52 51 फलाना डिकाना ये
टाइमर चल रही है एक मिनट के अंदर आपको
आईपी मिल जाएगी आईपी किसकी आईपी होगी आपकी
टारगेट की आईपी होगी अब इस टारगेट की आईपी
को हंट करना है कैसे करोगे दो तरीके
स्टार्ट अटैक बॉक्स जो है स्टार्ट कर लो
खुद का इसके लिए पेड सब्सक्रिप्शन चाहिए
तो पेड वाले तो आराम से कर लेंगे इन
ब्राउजर आपका एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ओपन हो
जाएगा बस यह मान के चलो इन ब्राउजर आपका
इनका खुद का तो कोई टेंशन नहीं करते रहो
या तो अगर आपका फ्री वाला है तो उसके लिए
आपको अपने मशीन को अपने नेटवर्क को ट्राई
हकमी के नेटवर्क में लेकर जाना होगा तभी
तो उनके नेटवर्क में जो डिप्लॉयड मशीनस है
उनसे इंटरेक्ट कर पाओगे ना
बाहर की मशीन किसी पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के अंदर कनेक्ट कब कर
पाएगी जब उनके नेटवर्क में आ जाएगी तभी कर
पाएगी ना भाई यह तो बताओ मुझे यह कांसेप्ट
पता है ना एक लाइन में तो लोकल नेटवर्क
एरिया में तो तुम एक मशीन दूसरे मशीन से
कम्युनिकेट कर पाती है जब वन में
कम्युनिकेट करेगी तो एक मीडियम तो होना
चाहिए ना जैसे आपको वन में कम्युनिकेट
करना है आपको राउटर चाहिए होता है एक
राउटर की रिक्वायरमेंट होती है यह बात पता
है ना
आपको नो प्लीज लेट मी नो
प्लीज लेट मी
नो यह बात आपको पता है चेकलिस्ट क्या होती
है अभी तो बताया यार चेकलिस्ट क्या होती
है चेकलिस्ट एक लिस्ट ऑफ लेबिलिटी आप
बनाओगे एंड उसके अकॉर्डिंग ही आप हंट
करोगे टारगेट पे स्टार्टिंग में पहला जो
आपने बनाया पहला जो आपने लिस्ट में डाला
वलन बिलिटी या बग पहले उसको हंट करोगे
उसको टिक मार्क कर दोगे कि हो गया फिर
दूसरे पे जाओगे तीसरे प जाओ ऐसे आप ट्रैक
कर पाओगे कि आपने कौन-कौन सी वटी फाइंड कर
ली या कौन-कौन से प ट्राई मार लि या
मिक्सर नहीं होगा क्योंकि आने वाले टाइम
में बहुत सारी बक्स की लिस्ट आपके पास
होगी अभी तो एक दो मिलेंगी बट बहुत सारी
लिस्ट वैसे आ जाएगी
राइट तो यहां
पे अब इनके नेटवर्क में आने के लिए ना
आपको यहां पे क्या करना है एक वीपीएन का
यूज करना है वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क
वर्चुअल प्राइवेट नेटवर्क ये आप है ये
ट्राई हकमी है बीच में एक वीपीएन है आप
वीपीएन से कनेक्ट करेंगे वीपीएन किसका है
वीपीएन किससे कनेक्ट कर देगा आपको ट्राई
हैमी के नेटवर्क से कनेक्ट कर देगा और आप
तीनों कनेक्ट हो जाएंगे यानी आप और ट्रा
हैक दोनों कनेक्ट हो जाएंगे और आप उसके
नेटवर्क में है तो आप उसकी मशीनस को
एक्सेस कर पाएंगे यूज कर
पाएंगे इजली यूज कर पाएंगे बहुत इ ठीक है
तो यह मशीन आपकी आ गई यह समझ में आ गई
आपको मशीन अब चलिए अब चलिए अब चलिए यहां
पे ये आईपी आ चुकी है पेड वालों के लिए
क्या है स्टार्ट द अटैक बॉक्स स्टार्ट द
अटैक बॉक्स अटैक बॉक्स स्टार्ट कीजिए
आपका एक इन ब्राउजर मस्त सा एक ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम स्टार्ट हो जाएगा कोई टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है कुछ नहीं करना है एकदम आराम से
रिलैक्स होके रहना है एंड आप अपनी जो भी
हंटिंग की चीजें हैं वो आप कर सकते हैं ये
देखिए जैसे अटैक बॉक्स स्टार्ट हो रहा है
थोड़ा टाइम लगता है अटैक बॉक्स को स्टार्ट
होने में थोड़ा वेट कर लीजिएगा स्टार्ट हो
जाएगा तो ये अभी स्टार्टिंग पे आ रहा है
कोई बात नहीं अब अगर आपके पास अटैक बॉक्स
का ऑप्शन आप प्रीमियम कस्टमर नहीं है आप
फ्री वाला करना चाहते हैं तो आपके पास एक
ऑप्शन है यहां पे
यूज काली मशीन यह प्रीमियम के लिए है
लेकिन अगर आप फ्री वाला करना चाहते हैं तो
आपको क्या करना है मैं आपको बता देता हूं
यहां पे चलेंगे यहां पे आप एक्सेस पे
क्लिक करके ओपन मैं इसको न्यू टाइम में
ओपन करता हूं या एक्सेस पर जब आएंगे तो
एक्सेस पे आएंगे तो एक ओपन वीपीएन का
डिटेल आपको यहां मिलेगा पेड वालों के लिए
काली लिक्स भी है अटैक बॉक्स भी है सब आप
यूज कर सकते हैं यहां पे आप फ्री वालों के
लिए ओपन वीपीएन के थ्रू कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं इसके लिए आपको करना क्या है ना गाइस
अगर अगर किसके लिए
अगर यहां पे आपको आना है यहां पे ओपन
वीपीएन जो है इस पर क्लिक करना है फ्री
वाले पे क्लिक करेंगे तो आपको किसके लिए
करना है
mac's पे आ जाता हूं अब विंडोज पे आने के
बाद आपको एक कॉन्फिन फाइल डाउनलोड करनी है
कौन सी ये वाली डाउनलोड माय कॉन्फिन फाइल
ये वाली डाउनलोड कर लेनी है यहां से भी
क्लिक करके डाउनलोड कर लोगे डाउनलोड करोगे
तो यह डाउनलोड हो जाएगा तो यहां पे मेरे
पास एक फाइल होगी
डाउनलोडेड लेट मी सी इसमें है ना हां ये
रही मैं इसको लार्ज आइकन पे बड़ा कर देता
हूं ये फाइल डाउनलोड हो गई है मन सशन ओन
vpnbook.com पे आप आके एंड डाउनलोड कर
सकते हैं फॉर 7 8 10 11s इसका सेटअप
डाउनलोड करके इंस्टॉल कर लीजिएगा जैसे
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट करके करते हैं एंड दैट इट
तो आपका यहां पे ओपन वीपीएन इस तरीके से
कुछ इंस्टॉल होके आ जाएगा इस तरह का कुछ
इंटरफेस आपको यहां पे मिल जाएगा बट यहां
पे आप जब ओपन वीपीएन को इंस्टॉल कर लेंगे
आपने कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल डाउनलोड कर ली
अपनी ये वाला ओपन वीपीएन वाली तो अब अपने
जब टास्क बार में आओगे ना नीचे यहां पे तो
ये ओपन वीपीएन का ये वाला जो ओपन वीपीएन
है डिस्कनेक्टेड शो करेगा एंड इस तरह का
एक आइकन आपको दिखेगा राइट क्लिक करना है
इस पे इस पे राइट क्लिक करना है इंपोर्ट
प्रोफाइल पे क्लिक करना है इंपोर्ट करना
है आपको प्रोफाइल इंपोर्ट प्रोफाइल पे
क्लिक करोगे अपलोड फाइल पे जाना है एंड
यहां ओपन वीपीएन वाली फाइल जो आपने
डाउनलोड की थी वो वाली सेलेक्ट करके ओपन
कर लेनी है जैसे ही ओपन करोगे आपका इस
तरीके
का दिखने लगेगा इस तरीके से यह प्रोफाइल आ
जाएगी अब इस पे क्लिक करोगे यह कनेक्ट कर
देगा यहां से कर लो या फिर यहां पे जाओ
राइट क्लिक करके एंड यहां पे कनेक्ट पे
क्लिक करो दोनों ही केस में ये कनेक्ट कर
देगा आपके ट्राई हैक म के सर्वर से ट्राई
हैक म के नेटवर्क में आप चले जाओगे चलिए
यहां पे मैं क्लिक करता हूं एंड वी आर नाउ
कनेक्टेड यहां पे मैक्शन सॉल्यूशन से आपको
दिख रहा होगा यहां पे यहां पे एक सवा की
आईपी आपकी मिल गई पब्लिक आईपी यहां पे एक
प्राइवेट आईपी आपको मिल गई प्राइवेट आईपी
जो आपको मिलती है वो जनरली लिसन वगैरह के
लिए यूज आप कर सकते हैं जब आप कनेक्ट कर
देंगे गाइस चलो मैं एक काम करता हूं मैं
यहां पे डिस्कनेक्ट करता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए मैं इसको डिस्कनेक्ट करता हूं मैं एक
डिस्कनेक्ट करता हूं मैं क्या करता हूं
इसको राइट साइड में करता हूं एंड मैं यहां
पे कमांड प्रोमट ओपन कर लेता हूं एंड यहां
पे आईपी
कॉन्फिन फिग एंड मैं देखता हूं यहां पे कि
मेरे पास कौन-कौन से नेटवर्क एडेप्टर्स
यहां पे हैं वायरलेस एडाप्टर यहां पे है
मेरे पास जो वाईफाई जो मेरा है ये मेरा है
बहुत बढ़िया एक इथरनेट एडाप्टर है अ ये
वीएम वेर का है ये वीएम वेर का है व v
एमवेयर वाली है यहां पे यहां पे ये अननोन
एडाप्टर यहां पे आपको एक एडॉप्टर दिखेगा
अननोन एडेप्टर लोकल एरिया कनेक्शन अननोन
एडेप्टर ओपन वीपीएन कनेक्ट डीसी एडेप्टर
इस तरह के कुछ आपको मिल रहा है आपको देखने
को मिल रहा है राइट अब क्या करते हैं गाइस
यहां पे कोई आईपीपी कुछ नहीं मिल रही हमें
अब मैं क्या करता हूं सेम में मैं इस ओपन
वीपीएन प्रोफाइल को कनेक्ट कर देता हूं
लेट्स कनेक्ट इट कनेक्ट हमने कर दिया अब
हम वापस से आईपी कॉन्फिन चलाएंगे एंड नाउ
दिस टाइम जब आप स्क्रॉल करोगे ऊपर स्क्रॉल
करोगे स्क्रॉल करोगे स्क्रॉल करोगे यू विल
गेट अननोन एडॉप्टर लोकल एरिया कनेक्शन में
एक आईपी आपको मिल चुकी है जो आईपी
आपको ये 10 18 27 92 जो आपको यहां दिखा
रही है 10 18 27 192 जो आपकी इंटरनल आईपी
है जो आपको मिली है फ्रॉम ट्रा हैक मी दिस
ओपन वीपीएन बोल लो इंटरनल आईपी आपको मिली
है जब आप इस पे जाएंगे ट्रा हैक मी
पे यहां पे यहां पे आप ट्राई हैक मी पे
चलते हैं यहां पे तो यहां रिफ्रेश पे
क्लिक करेंगे तो आपका यह शो करेगा कि
कनेक्टेड है एंड ये वही इंटरनल वर्चुअल
आईपी एड्रेस जो है आपको यहां पे दिखने को
मिल जाएगी इसका मतलब है जब आप कनेक्टेड ये
टिक मार्क आ गया यू आर वेल कनेक्टेड एंड
यू आर गुड टू गो अब आप ट्र हैक मी के
नेटवर्क के अंदर में है गाइस यू आर इनसाइड
ट्रा हैक म नेटवर्क अब आप कुछ भी करेंगे
चलेगा कुछ भी करेंगे मतलब क्या चलेगा क्या
क्या होगा जैसे मैं क्या करता हूं अ ये एक
मशीन है चलो इसको ये अभी स्टार्ट अटैक
बॉक्स अभी तक स्टार्ट नहीं हुआ इसको
टर्मिनेट कर देते हैं कोई बात नहीं व विल
टर्मिनेट इट अ लेट्स सर्च
हियर एंड यहां सर्च करते हैं ओस
[संगीत]
टॉप 20 टॉप
10 चलो यहां पर आ जाते हैं ओ टॉप 10 ये यह
मशीन स्टार्ट हो रही है इसको मैं अभी
क्लोज कर देता हूं चलो यह आ गई है टॉप 10
मैं यहां पे चलता हूं यहां पे स्टार्ट
मशीन पे यहां पे स्टार्ट मशीन का ऑप्शन है
यहां स्टार्ट मशीन प क्लिक कर देते हैं ये
मशीन स्टार्ट कर रही है यहां पे आईपी डस
थोड़ी देर में आ जाएगी एंड
दैट्ची अब जब अब अब आईपी आगी ना अब देखो
क्या होगा अब देखो व्हाट इज हैपनिंग देखो
मैं क्या करता हूं इसको वीपीएन को
डिस्कनेक्ट करता हूं फिलहाल के लिए
डिस्कनेक्ट कर देता हूं डिस्कनेक्ट कर
देता हूं एंड यहां पे चलोगे नेटवर्क
एक्सेस में रिफ्रेश करोगे यहां पे अब ये
कनेक्शन क्लोज दिखाएगा देखो कनेक्टेड नहीं
है वी आर नॉट कनेक्टेड एनीमोर राइट अब
चलिए आईपी को आने देते हैं पहले लेट द
आईपी कम आईपी को आ जाने देते हैं ठीक है
बोर तो नहीं हो रहे भाई भाई कोई बोर हो
रहा है
क्या एनी वन गेटिंग बोर्ड जो बोर्ड हो रहा
है कुछ नहीं कर सकता मैं ये बोर होने वाली
चीज नहीं है भाई बोर हो जाओगे तो बग बंटी
हंटर कैसे बनोगे प्रो कैसे
बनोगे वेलकम योही यो
हाई काफी लोग हैं यार अभी तो लाइव में चलो
बढ़िया है अच्छा लग रहा है आप लोग अगर ऐसे
ही प्रेजेंस बना के रखोगे ना ऐसे ही
प्रेजेंस रखोगे ना मैं एक से क्वालिटी
कंटेंट लेकर आऊंगा बग बाउटी की यह मेरा
आपसे वादा
है चलिए
तो आईपी आ चुकी है गाइस हियर वी हैव द
आईपी अब मैं क्या करता हूं ना मैं एक काम
करता हूं ठीक है मैं नेटवर्क में कनेक्टेड
नहीं हूं ट्रायक म के व्हाट आई एम गोइंग
टू डू मैं यहां पे एसएसआरएफ पे चलता हूं
यहां पे एक यहां पे नीचे आओगे तो यहां पे
बोल रहा है ये एक लैब है छोटा सा एक
एग्जाम एक लैब है छोटा सा अभी हम कुछ नहीं
कर रहे बस एग्जांपल के लिए देख रहे हैं ये
बोल रहा है कि नेविगेट टू दिस वेयर यू विल
फाइंड अ सिंपल वेब एप्लीकेशन इस पे आपको
नेविगेट करना है तो एक एप्लीकेशन आपको
सिंपल एप्लीकेशन मिलेगी ठीक है तो ये कौन
सी आईपी है 10
106.7 ये आपकी यही आईपी है मशीन की 10
101.7 तो चलो अच्छी बात है यार तो इसको हम
इस परे नेविगेट करते हैं तो मैं कॉपी कर
देता हूं लिंक को एंड यहां पर मैं ओपन
करता हूं एंटर अब यह देखो ओपन हो रहा है
क्या लिंक इट्स नॉट गेटिंग ओपन चलो और आप
लोगों से बस एक ही चीज की रिक्वेस्ट
करूंगा मैं गाइस एक चीज ही बस आपसे
मांगूंगा इस पूरे सीरीज पूरे जर्नी में कि
अगर हो सके आपकी कृपा हो अगर आपकी आपका
इच्छा आपकी आप सबकी इच्छा हो तो आप
वीडियोस को चारों तरफ शेयर कर दो
उसके अलावा कुछ नहीं नथिंग एल्स नथिंग
एल्स ठीक है चलिए तो यहां पे यह पेज ओपन
नहीं हो रही है बट अब मैं क्या करूंगा
व्हाट आई एम गोइंग टू डू मैं स्टार्ट
बॉक्स स्टार्ट अटैक बॉक्स प क्लिक करूंगा
और अटैक बॉक्स को स्टार्ट करूंगा जो हमारा
अटैक बॉक्स यहां पे मिलता है उसको स्टार्ट
करूंगा तो अटैक बॉक्स को प्रोविजन होने
में थोड़ा टाइम लगता है तो आपको वेट करना
पड़ेगा मशीन को इनिला इज करके मशीन आपके
सामने आएगी इसमें थोड़ा आपको टाइम लग जाता
है थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिएगा एंड इट विल कम
अलोंग ओके
चलिए लेट्स सी लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग
16 पर तुरंत फास्ट होके यह कनेक्ट हो
जाएगा ठीक है तो इतना काम तो कर सकते हो
ना शेयरिंग तो कर सकते हो ना कम से कम यह
तो आपके हाथ में है यह टोटली आपके हाथ में
बोल रहा हूं आप जितना फैलाना है फैला दो
जितना ज्यादा आप सपोर्ट जितना प्यार
दिखाओगे जितना फैलाओ ग मैं उतना ही
क्वालिटी कंटेंट लेकर आऊंगा और मैं आपसे
बदले में एक ही चीज मांग रहा हूं बस
शेयरिंग शेयरिंग इ केरिंग तो सुना ही होगा
लेकिन शेयरिंग कर दो दोस्तों के बीच फैला
दो चारों तरफ भेज दो कि भैया यहां बग
बाउंट की सेशंस चल रही है यहां पे क्लासेस
चल रही है फ्री में चल रही है सब चीजें कर
दो ठीक है इतना कर दो बस
दैट्ची कर लेता हूं मैं क्या करता हूं मैं
क्या करता हूं मैं इसको कनेक्ट कर लेता
हूं मैं अपने फोन की स्क्रीन को ला देता
हूं ओके यह पब्लिक वाईफाई से कनेक्टेड है
यह ये य वार्निंग दे रहा है अच्छी बात है
पहले हम इसको कर लेते
हैं लेट इट स्टार्ट चलिए स्टार्ट हो रहा
है तब तक मैं इसको ला ही देता हूं अलाउ कर
देते हैं इसको स्क्रीन शेयर कर देते हैं
एंड इसको मिरर कर देते हैं या फिर वर्चुअल
कर देते
हैं
ओके एंड एक्सेप्ट कर लेते
हैं चलिए तब तक मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर दिया
मैंने इसको मैंने साइड में कर दिया
क्योंकि कुछ चीज आपको मैं दिखाऊंगा यू हैव
टू सी दैट ओके
चलिए लेट्स सी इट्स ऑलमोस्ट अबाउट टू गेट
प्रोविजन होने वाला है हां जी तो यह आने
वाली है अभी हमारे बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया
बढ़िया
[संगीत]
गुड गुड सो सो वी आर हियर नाउ वेरी नाइस
चलिए तो अब हमारा ये मशीन आ चुका है अब हम
इस मशीन के अंदर में ना हम इस मशीन के
अंदर में वो वाली आईपी खोलेंगे जो आईपी
यहां पे हमें बताया गया है ओपन करने के
लिए हम इसको ओपन करेंगे तो व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू इसको मैं यहां पे कॉपी लिंक
कर देता हूं कॉपी जब आप करेंगे ना ट्राई
हैक में तो यहां पे आना है आपको
क्लिपबोर्ड पे आना है यहां पे आपको पेस्ट
करना है ये आपको पेस्ट आपको हो जाएगा और
यहां से आप अब कॉपी करके एंड इसमें यूज कर
सकते ये थोड़ा सा लोचा है बट कोई बात नहीं
अब आप इसमें जाएंगे इसके ब्राउजर में अटैक
बॉक्स के ब्राउजर में क्योंकि अटैक बॉक्स
क्या है ना गाइस अटैक बॉक्स ये अटैक बॉक्स
जो है ना ये इनके ही नेटवर्क में काम कर
रहा है तो अब यहां पे ये आईपी ओपन करके
देखते हैं दिस आईपी एंड लेट्स
ओपन जैसे ही हमने ओपन किया वी हैव अ वेब
पेज जैसा कि इन्होंने बोला है कि यू विल
फाइंड अ सिंपल वेब एप्लीकेशन बढ़िया बट
यही आईपी अगर हम अपने ब्राउजर में ओपन कर
रहे हैं वी आर गोइंग टू ओपन इन आवर ओन
ब्राउजर देन यह ओपन नहीं होगा क्यों
क्योंकि हम ट्रा हकमी के नेटवर्क से
कनेक्ट नहीं है बट अब हम ओपन वीपीएन से
क्या करेंगे बोलेंगे कि कनेक्ट हो जा व
विल से कनेक्ट टू ट्रा हैक म नेटवर्क और
हमने कनेक्ट कर दिया अब हम इस वेब पेज को
वापस से रीलोड करेंगे एंड जैसे ही रीलोड
करेंगे यू विल सी कि आप अपने लैपटॉप अपने
नेटवर्क में ना इस वेब पेज को ओपन कर सकते
हो यू कैन ओपन इन योर ओन नेटवर्क क्योंकि
हम कनेक्टेड हैं अब ट्राई हकमी के नेटवर्क
से ओपन वीपीएन के थ्रू ये चीज आपको समझनी
पड़ेगी जब ट्राई हैक मी यूज़ करना शुरू
करोगे तो एवरीवन गॉट इट इतना समझ में आ
गया सबको चलिए ये दिखाना था मैं क्लोज कर
देता हूं कनेक्शंस को यहां पे क्योंकि
मेरा अभी इसका कोई काम है नहीं यहां पे
मैं अटैक बॉक्स को भी क्लोज कर देता हूं
क्योंकि अभी भी अभी अटैक बॉक्स का भी कोई
काम नहीं है सिस्टम को भी इस मशीन को भी
टर्मिनेट कर देता हूं क्योंकि अभी इसका
कोई काम नहीं है एंड
दैट्ची जो हमारा है है ना उसी पे मिलेगा
तो
whatsapp's पे तो जो ये अनाउंसमेंट वाली
वीडियो है ना बग बाउंट ट्रेनिंग की जब आप
इसको ओपन कर लेंगे इसके जब डिस्क्रिप्शन
में जाएंगे यहां पे तो यहां पे फॉलो एंड
जॉइन
चैनल जॉइन क्योंकि जो भी अपडेट्स आएंगी
गाइस आपके उसी
[संगीत]
जो रिसोर्सेस आएंगे जैसे अभी मैं करा रहा
हूं बग बाउटी मैं जो रिसोर्सेस आपको
प्रोवाइड करूंगा जैसे यह चीटशीट यह जो
चीटशीट है यह ओस पॉली चीट शीट इसको मैं
अपलोड कर दूंगा कहां अपलोड करूंगा भैया
कहां डालूंगा ये डालूंगा आपके हमारे
डेनिक्स एडमी ए एप्लीकेशन पे तो आपको ए
एप्लीकेशन आपको प् स्टर पे जाना है एंड
आपको डेनिक्स अकेडमी जो है वो सर्च करके
एंड यहां पे डिफ सर्च करके एंड यहां पे
इसको इंस्टॉल कर लेना है इसको ओपन कर लेना
है जब आप ओपन करोगे डिनीस अकेडमी ए प तो
यहां पे आपको ये वाली एक कोर्स मिलेगी ये
फ्री कोर्स फ्री कोर्स इस पे आपको आ जाना
है फ्री कोर्स का नाम है इसका ये ₹10
क्योंकि आपको बताया ही था यार वेंडर्स
अलाउड नहीं करते कंप्लीट फ्री आपको इसको
इसमें जवाइन कर लेना है ₹10 वाली एंड यहां
पे कंटेंट वाले में आपको रिसोर्सेस
मिलेंगे यहां पे फ्री रिसोर्सेस वाली जो
ऑप्शन है इसमें आपको मिलेगा अभी तो नहीं
देख सकते अभी हां देख तो सकते हैं ये मिल
जा रहा है बढ़िया है ब बाकी यहां पे जो
लाइव सेशंस यहां पे बग बाउंट के जो डाउट
सेशंस होंगे ना आपके वो ऐप में होंगे इसी
कोर्स के अंदर होंगे संडे संडे होंगे
मोस्ट प्रोबेबली जबजब होगा आपको नोटिफाई
कर दिया जाएगा जो भी डाउट सेशन मतलब आपसे
कोई डिस्कशन लाइव इंटरेक्ट करेंगे हम ऐप
के अंदर में इस बग बाउंट सीरीज के लिए हम
इस ऐप के अंदर में इसी कोर्स के अंदर में
लाइव इंटरेक्ट करेंगे तो आपको इसमें आ
जाना है जवाइन कर लेना है ठीक है ताकि
आपको मैं नोटिफाई कर पाऊं ताकि मैं आपको
चीजें बता पाऊं कब आ रहा हूं लाइव कब क्या
करना है कौन से टॉपिक्स पर डिस्कशन करने
हैं पहले भी यहां पे बहुत सारे लाइव सेशंस
हुए हैं तो ये तीन चार लाइव सेशंस हुए हैं
बट अब बग बाउंट के ऊपर स्पे फोकस पे लाइव
सेशन होंगे वहां पे आप मेरे से ऑडियो में
बात कर पाएंगे यू कैन टॉक टू मी इस ऐप के
अंदर में आप मुझसे बात कर पाएंगे अपनी
क्वेश्चंस कर पाएंगे हम डिस्कशंस कर
पाएंगे हम कुछ चीजें पे हम सामने भी
कुछ-कुछ चीजें कर पाएंगे एक साथ मिलके कर
पाएंगे तो ये बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी हो जाता
है यह काम आप कर लीजिएगा ठीक है एंड थर्ड
थिंग इज कि हमारा एथिकल हैकिंग का साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का एक कंप्लीट कोर्स है अगर आप
इंटरेस्टेड है ना इसमें भी वक बाउंट बिगनर
लेवल का बताए गया है तो आप इसको कर सकते
हैं इसमें बहुत सारे कंसेप्ट हैं बहुत
सारे टॉपिक्स हैं टॉपिक्स देखोगे तो दिमाग
खराब हो जाएगा यह सर्टिफिकेशंस आपको मिलती
है मैं ज्यादा कुछ नहीं बताऊंगा ये ये आप
डोमेन पे आ जाना de.com साइब सिक्योरिटी
मास्ट कोर्स पे आपको ये सारे टॉपिक्स
इसमें मिलते हैं इफ यू आर इंटरेस्टेड यू
कैन गो विद दैट अदर वाइज आप बग बाउंट को
कंटिन्यू कीजिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है तो
बग बांटी के अंदर अभी तो हमने शुरुआत की
है हमने जस्ट स्टार्ट किया है वी हैव जस्ट
स्टार्टेड इन बग बाउंट अभी तो बचा है अभी
तो बहुत कुछ बचा है भाई सर अटैक बॉक्स के
लिए क्या करना पड़ेगा अरे यार अटैक बॉक्स
के लिए कुछ नहीं करना है अटैक बॉक्स के
लिए अटैक बॉक्स से स्टार्ट कर दो यहां पे
स्टार्ट अटैक क् हो जाएगा ये प्रेड चीज है
अटैक बॉक्स एंड काली बोथ आर पेड ये पेड है
ठीक है ये पेड वाली चीज है फ्री वाली चीज
ओपन वीपीएन है फ्री वाला में ओपन वीपीएन
को कनेक्ट करके आप कर सकते हो ठीक है
बिल्कुल बिगनर वाले भी कर सकते हैं
एब्सलूट कर सकते हैं भैया बिगनर वालों के
लिए ही तो है मैंने बताया तो आपको बिल्कुल
एब्सलूट बिगनर वालों के लिए भी है मैंने
आपको ऑलरेडी बताया कि ऑलरेडी दिस दिस
कोर्स फॉर एब्सलूट बिगिनर्स आल्सो
बिगिनर्स के लिए ही तो है भैया मैं कहां
बोला कि एक्सपीरियंस कैंडिडेट के लिए है
ओनली नहीं नहीं सबके लिए है तो आपको करना
क्या है कीप लर्निंग एंड प्रैक्टिसिंग कीप
लर्निंग एंड प्रैक्टिसिंग बी अ लर्नर
अर्निंग विल कम एक लर्नर बरो अर्निंग
ऑटोमेटिक आ जाएगी ऑटोमेटिक अर्न करने
लगोगे फोकस ऑन कंसेप्ट कांसेप्ट पे फोकस
करो बहुत ज्यादा बहुत ज्यादा आपके लिए
यूजफुल रहेगा फोकस करना है आपको कांसेप्ट
पे एंड सेट योर टारगेट एंड प्लान
अकॉर्डिंग टारगेट सेट करना है उसके
अकॉर्डिंग प्लान करना है उसी को
एग्जीक्यूट करना है इसी तरीके से आगे आपको
बढ़ते जाना है बाकी चीजें डेनिक्स एडमी
youtube1 की चीजें मिल जाएंगी जो भी चीजें
समझनी है मान लो तुम्हें क्या करना है
लेट्स सपोज तुम्हें क्या करना है काली
लिनिक्स पूरी सीखनी है बिल्कुल फ्री में
सीखनी है डिफर अकेडमी
youtube1 वीडियोस हैं एक वीडियोस का एवरेज
ड्यूरेशन डेढ़ घंटे का है सीख जाओ सीख
जाओगे ओसीन सीख जाओगे एसक्यूएल सीख जाओगे
बैच पूरा कंप्लीट कर लो क्योंकि बक बाउंट
का जब एक फेज आएगा तो वहां पे बैश जो है
ना आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट हो सकता है उसके
बाद आप नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की वीडियोस
वीडियोज वाले सेक्शन में आओगे तो नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी के वीडियोस मिलेंगे आप इनको भी
देख जाओ ठीक है ये भी चीज आप देख सकते हो
और काली की इंस्टॉलेशन काली को कैसे
पर्सिन बनाना है लाइव यूएसबी बूट करना है
लाइव यूबी बूटेबल कैसे बनानी है वो सारी
चीजें यहां पे आपको दी गई है काली को आप
विंडोज के
अंदर डब्लू एएल के अंदर कैसे इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हैं ये वाला भी आप देख लीजिएगा
वीडियो डब्ल्यू एएल के अंदर काली को कैसे
चलाना है ये वाली आप वीडियो सेक्शन में
काली l इंस्टॉलेशन इस पे आ जाइएगा एंड
यहां पे आप इसको देख जाइएगा क्योंकि आप
फिर विंडोज में भी काली को चला पाएंगे
डायरेक्टली लए के अंदर में ठीक है तो वीएम
वेर की जरूरत कई कुछ हद तक आपको नहीं
पड़ेगी बट स्टिल वीएम वेर इज वीएम वेर
वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट इज वर्चुअल एनवायरमेंट
वो तो आपको करना ही करना है ये काम आपको
कर लेना है ठीक है ये सारे काम आपको कर
लेने हैं एंड एंड अगर आपको कुछ आर्टिकल्स
वगैरह पढ़ने हैं अच्छे-अच्छे अ कुछ यूनिक
आर्टिकल्स तो वो भी हम लेकर आते जा रहे
हैं हमारे di.com वेबसाइट पे आइएगा
ब्लॉग्स पे आ जाइएगा ब्लॉग्स पे जब आएंगे
तो यहां पे आपको अलग-अलग आर्टिकल्स देखने
को को मिलेंगे आने वाले टाइम में और भी
अपडेट मिलेंगे कुछ अच्छे-अच्छे आर्टिकल्स
मिलेंगे आप उनको पढ़ सकते हैं ठीक है
दैट्ची लॉग इन करके सेम नंबर से एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं सेम नंबर से आप ए प पे भी लॉगइन
करके एक्सेस कर सकते हैं कोर्सेस को लाइफ
टाइम के लिए ठीक है तो ये चीज हो गई अब
यहां पे मैं आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं ये
तो हमने बस शुरुआत करा है वी हैव जस्ट
स्टार्टेड इन बग बांटी जस्ट स्टार्टेड अभी
हमने बस स्टार्ट करा है इसको हम बहुत आगे
लेकर जाएंगे एंड यकीन मानो हम लाइव टारगेट
पे भी हंट करेंगे हम अ हम लैब्स को भी
सॉल्व करेंगे हम डिफरेंट डिफरेंट काइंड
ऑफ़ सिनेरियो लाएंगे लाइव बग बाउंट करेंगे
लाइव टारगेट पे वो भी टाइम आएगा थोड़ा वेट
करो सबर करो उसका फल मीठा होता है ठीक है
वेट करोगे बहुत फ्रूटफुल अ आपका जो है ना
वो फ्रू जो रिजल्ट मिलेगा वो बहुत
फ्रूटफुल होगा बहुत मजा आएगा तो आज का
सेशन कैसा लगा मुझे बता दो जल्दी से जल्दी
मुझे बता दो चैट में कैसा लगा आज का सेशन
क्योंकि बहुत ज्यादा लंबा नहीं करेंगे फिर
आपके दिमाग से निकलेगा नेक्स्ट सेशन कब
होगी कैसे होगी देखो टाइमिंग तो वही होगी
7 पीएम के बाद ही होगी जब भी होगी बट कब
होगी वो आपको
ैनो देखते रहिएगा चेक आउट करते रहिएगा तो
अब मुझे आप बता दीजिए जल्दी
से
बता द जल्दी से कैसा लगा आपको कैसा
लगा कैसा लगा आपको आज का सेशन रिव्यू
प्लीज रिव्यू दीजिए मुझे रिव्यू दीजिए और
मेरे साथ बने रहिए नेक्स्ट कोर्स नेक्स्ट
क्लासेस में भी एंड बिलीव मी ना मैं आपको
प्रो नहीं बनाया ना बग बाउटी का तो तुम
केस कर देना मेरे ऊपर जाओ जाओ केस फाइल कर
देना जाओ कि भैया मुझे प्रो नहीं बनाया
लिख के दे रहा हूं ना प्रो बना के रहूंगा
चाहे कुछ भी हो जाओ व्हाट एवर हैपेंस आई
विल मेक यू बग बांटी
हंटर अब देखो बहुत अब लेवल पे जाओगे ना तो
उसके लिए खुद से एक्सप्लोर करना है और हां
जितना मैं बताऊं सिर्फ उतना ही नहीं पढ़ना
है जितना मैं बताऊं उससे 10 गुना ज्यादा
एक्सप्लोर करके आना है खुद ही जितना मैंने
अभी बताया उसको और एक्सप्लोर करके आओ
नेक्स्ट सेशन में ठीक है एक दिन का कम से
कम गैप दूंगा मैं अगले सेशन में हर सेशन
के नेक्स्ट सेशन के के बीच में ना एक दिन
का तो कम से कम एटलीस्ट गैप होगा एक या दो
दिन का क्योंकि आपको वो चीज समझनी पड़ेगी
आपको वो चीज प्रैक्टिस करनी है जो मैं
बताऊं प्रैक्टिस करनी है अब जैसे आज का
सेशन तो नॉर्मल था तो नेक्स्ट सेशन मे बी
एक दिन के बाद ही हो जाए ठीक है तो आपको
whatsapp2 में देख लो यार यहां पे
ओके अरे यहीं पे अपलोडेड मिलेगी ना भैया
यहीं पे अपलोड मिलेगी आपको यहीं पर
अपलोडेड मिलेगी टेंशन मत लो जो वीडियोस है
यहीं पर अपलोडेड मिलेगी बट लाइव का एक अलग
ही मजा है है
ना
चलो अच्छा लगा बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक
यू गाइस फॉर योर
रिव्यूज थैंक यू फॉर योर ऑसम रिव्यूज अब
आपको क्या करना है आपको पता है ना आपको
क्या करना है मुझे जरा आपसे एक ही चीज
मांगी है और व चीज आपको करना है क्या करना
है मुझे बताओ यह सोशल मीडिया प्लेटफार्म
है हमारे आप इन पर हमसे कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं youtube0 ा टेलीग्राम ए प आपको क्या
करना
है ताहिर सर आपके बारे में फ्रेंड्स से
सुना है बट आप तो उससे ज्यादा ग्रेट एंड
स्वीट है अरे ताहिर ताहिर ताहिर मुजावर
थैंक यू सो मच ब्रदर ताहिर भाई बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद ऐसी अच्छी बातें बोलने के लिए
चलिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद शेयर करना है थैंक
यू सो मच शेयर कीजिएगा आप लोग प्लीज शेयर
कीजिएगा और डिफ अकेडमी ैनू को अभी तक
सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा तो सब्सक्राइब करो
बेल आइकन को हिट करो ताकि नोटिफिकेशन मिले
नोटिफिकेशन मिलेगी तभी तो आओगे ना और चेक
करते रहना कम्युनिटी टैब भी और अपडेट्स भी
कि कब कब लाइव शेड्यूल हो रही है आपकी ठीक
है चलिए अब नेक्स्ट सेशन में नेक्स्ट सेशन
में ना और धमाका होने वाला है भाई क्योंकि
प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट स्टार्ट होंगे ना लैब
स्टार्ट होंगी हंटिंग स्टार्ट होगी रेकन
को पूरा चीड़ फाड़ देना है रेकन को एकदम
बेसिक से एकदम लेके जाना है मास्टर करना
है रेकन मास्टर कर लोगे बाकी वलने
एबिलिटीज बहुत आसानी से तुम कवर कर लोगे
रेकन को एकदम से रकॉन के देखना कितने
सेशंस होंगे घबराना नहीं है रे कन से तुम
बग्स फाइंड करोगे मैं आपको बताता हूं ना
यार विदन टू थ्री मंथ्स ना तुम लाइव हंट
करके और वैलिड वर्क फाइंड करने लगोगे
थोड़ी मेथड इस को आपको चेंज करनी पड़ेगी
अपनी एंड जितना मैं पढ़ा हूं उससे 10 गुना
ज्यादा एक्सप्लोर करना है तभी सीखो जितना
मैं पढ़ा उतने प रुक जाओगे तो उतने ही प
रुक जाओगे सही में एक्सप्लोर खुद से करना
है अभी पढ़ लिया अब जो जो चीज बताई उसको
जाके इंटरनेट को छान मारना इंटरनेट को
खंगा लो जो बोला उसको और एक्सप्लोर करो यू
विल लर्न अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स
चलिए नहीं लाइव वेबसाइट पर टेस्ट करने के
कोई वीपीएन जरूरत नहीं हम उसी टारगेट पर
टेस्ट करेंगे जिसका हमें ऑलरेडी परमिशन
मिला हुआ है हमें ऑलरेडी परमिशन मिली हुई
है उसी पर हम टेस्ट करेंगे ठीक
है
कौन सा लिंक डाल दिए हो डार्क वेब प भाई
हैकर है
आटो चलो
धन्यवाद
चलिए
[संगीत]
अ वीपीएन की जरूरत नहीं है चलिए तो आज के
सेशन के लिए इतना ही करते हैं गाइस एंड
इतना ही इतने प सेशन एंड करते हैं सो थैंक
यू सो मच गाइस एंड रियली रियली इट वाज अ
वेरी ग्रेट सेशन आप इतने लोग ने सेशन
ज्वाइन करा इतने लोगों ने यहां पे
प्रेजेंस अपनी बनाई आप नेक्स्ट सेशन में
भी ऐसे ही आइएगा और ज्यादा मजा आएगा आपको
और भी ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग लगेगा और भी
ज्यादा आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा
क्योंकि हम हंटिंग स्टार्ट करेंगे ठीक है
और बहुत कुछ करेंगे बहुत ज्यादा कुछ
करेंगे तो प्लीज डोंट मिस एनी ऑफ द सेशन
जो मिस थोड़ा बहुत कर दिया जब ये वीडियो
एंड होगी तो आपकी रिकॉर्डिंग जब आ जाएगी
ना अ तो उसको आप देखिएगा प्लीज उसको भी आप
देखिएगा एंड देन अ आपको बहुत कुछ जानने को
सीखने को मिलेगा सो थैंक यू सो मच एंड गुड
नाइट सबको एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में
whatsapp2 क्लास में मिलेंगे ठीक है तो
चलिए सबको टाटा बाय बाय एंड हैव अ गुड
नाइट एंड हैव अ ग्रेट नाइट हैव अ ग्रेट डे
अहेड अगले दिन का भी आपका अच्छा हो सब कुछ
बढ़िया हो एंड थैंक यू थैंक यू सो मच